this is Jocko podcast number 360 with
Dave Burke and me Jocko willink good
evening Dave good evening
the secretary of the Navy takes pleasure
in presenting the Navy Commendation
Medal to lieutenant Thomas kopel for
services set forth in the following
citation
for Heroic achievement as a pilot of jet
aircraft while attached to Fighter
Squadron
142 embarked in USS Constellation
on 14 January 1970 Lieutenant Coppell
flew the wing aircraft of a two-plane
attack mission in Southeast Asia
despite heavy anti-aircraft fire in the
area he placed all of his bombs on
target resulting in five enemy trucks
destroyed and many secondary explosions
and many enemy casualties
his professional determination in spite
of heavy anti-aircraft fire and adverse
weather conditions resulted in a
substantial damage to the enemy's
Logistics efforts
Lieutenant coppell's superb airmanship
courage and Devotion to duty reflected
great credit upon himself and weren't
keeping with the highest traditions
of the United States Naval service
the combat distinguishing device is
authorized
for the secretary m f Wisner
vice admiral United States Navy
and that is a citation
that represents the types of missions
that were flown by Navy Fighters day
after day night after night week after
week month after month
year after year
those were the type of missions
that resulted in
solid battle damage to the enemy
but also resulted in
532 aircraft lost in combat 401 aviators
killed 64 missing 179 captured
who became prisoners of War
75 of those aircrafts that were shot
down were F4 Phantoms
foreign
these missions were flown by pilots who
took incredible risks to get the job
done and eventually Pilots that re-wrote
the book on air-to-air combat and laid
the foundation for how fighter pilots
are trained to this very day
and it's an honor to have one of these
Pilots here with us tonight
that pilot in fact is from the opening
award citation
Tom Coppell Tom thanks for coming down I
appreciate you coming out here everyone
know we got Dave he
he used to keep me honest
well he's always done that he's always
excited the few times I've had some
pilots on without having Dave on or he's
not happy about it
so uh we got him here and I guess let's
let's just kind of start from the
beginning and how you grew up and where
you came from so you were you were born
in uh in Queens is that right yeah
Jamaica Hospital huge Hospital in Queens
but we lived just over the City Line in
a new development that the house was
built and my parents moved in with a
brand new baby and this was 19 what 41.
so you're pre-war yeah and my dad was
not drafted because of me
[Music]
he was an insurance underwriter in the
financial district of insurance District
of downtown downtown
Manhattan Nassau Street in those places
down there and a nice guy I have to say
well that's good how how much
um
you know so you're born in 1941
probably I'm assuming before the war
started before Pearl Harbor I was yeah
August and Pearl Harbor was in December
okay yeah do you so as you're growing up
is there any part of World War II that
you remember
I remember my mother telling me that the
war in Japan was over I don't remember
her telling me that the war in Europe
was over
um on the other hand since I was four
years old and had a brand new sister
they sort of left me alone and I would
go down to the corner believe it or not
what was then I guess it probably still
is Hillside Avenue and I used to see
lowboy trucks with uh Grumman uh
uh it certainly were F6 uh Fighters with
the wings removed they put the fuselage
and the wings on the side I think the
engines and propellers were on them but
obviously they were on their way to
South Pacific and asked your mother what
the heck is that and
oh they're going to war and stuff like
that so uh I I assumed that was 1944 I
was three years old sitting on the curb
and that's the first ever member of any
of that but they told me that both
Grumman and Republic were
out in the island at that time I guess
it was more Farms did that leave an
impression on you seeing the fighters I
mean first of all yeah I don't remember
anything until I was about 17 I think so
you remember seven three is pretty
impressive
um but but did you think oh these are
these are warplanes going to war did not
make any sense to you oh yes oh yes that
was but I never expected that I would be
a guy who would fly them or anything
like that and the other thing I I
remember about flying machines was uh
was not combat or war or anything like
that was the fact that Idlewild that
became JFK when they expanded at the
airport was seeing the uh the
dc-7bs coming in from Europe in bad
weather they use the East-West Runway
and uh
streaming fire out of the back of the
off the top of the Wings and how the
heck is that so I finally
in my grown-up days talked to a guy
who's a retired Naval aviator P p3s or
he's semi I said Dennis why why didn't
you uh want to be a carrier guys many
engines Tom oh
that but at any rate he was a flight
engine here on on dc-7bs and he said
that's because a flight engineer goes
full rich and
Flames I'm roaring out the back and
especially in foggy weather when they're
you know oh so that's what you'd be
seeing yeah I wanted to do that that's
really hot stuff you know but but and uh
well and jumping ahead I guess but uh
why did I ever want to go with I wanted
to my father said I graduated from
college my dad said what are you going
to do and I said I don't know he said
why don't you see if one of the services
would teach you how to fly I said don't
take guys like me he said they sure do
well before you get to College what was
growing up like so did you grow up there
just outside the city yeah and I was
just a kid uh
um
a four-year-old kid down on the corner
at Hillside Avenue by yourself which is
cool yeah but that was different time I
think or something like maybe there was
many monsters around men as there are
now but nobody talked about or acted
that way and as soon as I got a bike you
know
then it was really awesome yeah I was
never there were you how'd you do in
school did you like it's terrible I
hated school
I hated school I was a my wife loves to
tease me that I was such a terrible
little monster that the one of the
classrooms that I I was in in grade
school
had a it was at the two classrooms at
the end of the hallway and then a
connecting room between the two she put
me in the connecting room with a door
that opened so I could see the
Blackboard but I was in the room with
the door open about 10 inches wide
you're just a hyperactive kid I I think
so and the board with all of that I
could read before I was Bri I could read
when I was four so many were always
buying me books so uh
stuff like that so you are smart but
bored I guess I don't know what about
sports were you into sports at all
yeah because I was the big biggest kid
and uh played touched football in high
school which got I'm sorry in grade
school seventh and eighth grade and it
gets a little rough at least it did that
so but I never got hurt or anything like
that and then when I got to high school
I played
played football and
played first team what year did you
graduate high school 59. so you grew up
in like the iconic uh 50s that's right
when you see those movies or you just I
think it's awful why is it awful the
clothes that they wear and the Nostalgia
the cars we real I do today or death
traps but they bring huge money these
cars did you which one did you have you
must have had one did you have one I
guess maybe not in the city no it's not
the city it was real suburbs wooden
houses on little bitty little bitty Lots
so did you have a car
uh no I you know what I never owned a
car until uh I was in flying school in
Big Spring yeah Big Spring Texas
uh never had a need of one got around
back in the 50s
early 60s you stick out your thumb you
gotta ride
um people were different than somehow or
other I don't really understand how that
is but I want all of the the eastern
half of the United States with my phone
I went everywhere
and never worried about getting back or
anything like that but on one time the
worst time ever had doing that was on
the Pennsylvania Turnpike in Western
Pennsylvania I was there for 12 hours
no one would pick me up I have no idea
why and maybe I'd look scholarly or
something like that I don't know I don't
think I would have been a great
hitchhiker if it comes down to look at
scouting I would definitely have some
issues so you're growing up in the
iconic 50s how do those movies miss the
mark hit the mark I mean how are they
the 50s movies yeah I don't know I don't
I frankly I don't remember
um
I don't remember what movies you might
be talking about what about Elvis you
remember I thought it was awful you
thought Elvis was awesome I personally
did I guess my sister's thought
otherwise three younger sisters
but I thought that was the dumbest thing
I ever heard of so that's what I thought
so what were you listening to
I have to admit classical music
a minor story my wife
when before we were married
somehow or other I introduced her to the
fact that I listened mostly to classical
music
and she went home she tells me now or
actually after we were married I said
this guy is a little bit weird suspect
for his sister classical music
I don't know I've
rimsky-korsakov Shara shaherazade that
everybody knows I've I'm really
intrigued by that so
So I listened to classical music and
still do today so whatever so the rock
and roll thing was not your scene not
until the California British Invasion
and in California and that was all
together different okay we'll get there
so you you you graduate from high school
1959. so you lived through the Korean
War as well I remember it well I
remember being a Boy Scout camp when
they announced the uh Armistice uh had
just been signed that morning or
whatever it was so it was that was a big
deal everybody cheered but you still
didn't get the uh the impression that
that was something that you might do one
day no no there was no military
uh tradition in the family at all except
for
um a grand Uncle maximum nice guy who
was
a graduate of the same
College as Donald Trump graduated still
exists in New York state Military
Academy I think it's called and he but
he graduated in 1936 or something like
that and he was part of the last
combat Cavalry Regiment in the United
States Army and I was disbanded I think
in 1939 as the storm clouds were
gathering and they disbanded that unit
but that was that was officers with real
swords and two horses each and all the
rest of everything else about that but
that was a combat unit not a display you
know and it was the last one he wound up
in Iceland for the duration of the war
deriding the whole experience but I only
realized in my grown-up days that if
Hitler
had won the Battle of Britain Iceland
was next and they probably no doubt knew
that but they all I went to a reunion
with him at one point and they all
derided their experience there and so
forth but they would have been the first
to be killed in the first
super German raid no doubt on on Iceland
to flatten the place yeah we used to get
a similar thing in the SEAL Teams where
you'd get some platoons would be going
over to Iraq or Afghanistan
and some other platoons would be going
to
like Guam or some somewhere there's no
war going on and of course all the guys
that are get sent to Guam are just angry
that they can't be an Iraq or
Afghanistan and meanwhile the guys in
Iraq or Afghanistan are freezing or or
just sweating to death or they're
getting shot at or whatever so yeah they
use real bullets here and stuff like
that yeah but that's what you know
that's what people join the SEAL Teams
for yeah and uh apparently the horse
cavalry as well yeah it was for real
swords and the whole deal with with
those guys and he was a wonderful man
wonderful man
when sisters were born I got farmed out
with him twice in the summertime and uh
um he worked in lower New York State
Binghamton and Elmira those places
around there and he had Grand aunts who
had a truncated Farm there and
and he farmed me out with them he was a
slave labor and I heard this one I had
kid fun uh being a kid with corn fields
and ponds and stuff like that all over
the place there and
and then where'd you know so where'd you
end up going to college I went to
Albright College in Reading PA uh a
Commuter for me a very small college at
that time 850 students at that time and
now it's about 12 or 1300 maybe a little
bit more than that
but uh wonderful teachers they're
absolutely wonderful especially the men
but one notable woman who
was a pacifist of all things but she was
absolutely a wonderful woman and uh what
made what how come she left such a big
impression on you because she was so
strict I'd never met a woman quite like
that she was straightforward and
thoughtful and aggressive I like a woman
who is my wife
uh tells you what's on her mind
immediately and she was that way I guess
so and she was a professor there yeah
she was what was she teaching English uh
English and speech and um you've got to
be you got she changed to uh with her
professional abilities and so forth and
I remember sitting there arguing with
her silently uh no
attendant lecture about using the atomic
bomb in Japan she was opposed to that
and um
I don't think she had read notably or
widely enough about all that and I had
at that point and as opposed to that but
still I I thought she was really great
and the point of view sort of thing and
what were you studying I was uh uh econ
major not business economics and minor
in history
and
and had some fabulous teachers there
a guy named Wilbur Gingrich who was a
genuinely world famous
Greek scholar and biblical scholar
a couple of other guys that nobody ever
heard of but a wonderful man and uh
a crazy guy who taught loved to teach
European and Russian history and I took
him for Russian don't take him for God's
sakes he you've got a D out of that and
he'll blither you and you can't write
fast enough and his class kick his name
was no Gingrich was the uh the biblical
scholar and Greek scholar
um can you believe his name escapes me
but at any rate Kistler and they said
you'll get a d out of his class because
you can't write fast enough and stuff
like that but he he was something he
smoked uh continuously
well and always had the window open and
the butts went out the window and he'd
torch up another one
but he was he was really something and
be you got all of six in the class so at
some point you uh you got more into
school than you were when you were in
grammar school or whatever yeah no
because it had smart people who was
smarter than I was and uh uh uh how'd
you put it my parents weren't really
educated if you will my mother had a
college degree from NYU but I think she
skated as much as she could my and my
dad they kicked him out of grade school
I'm yeah out of school when he was uh
after uh 10th grade I think because he
was done they did that at that time in
the 20s so uh both of them wanted me to
be educated and so forth so that it was
it was interesting to be in the company
of genuinely educated people and I I
didn't catch fire at first by the time I
was a junior I understood that this is
really an experience you can get uh
interesting things out of these people
by the time I was a senior I didn't want
to leave because I
you get to talk as a grown-up with these
grown-ups who listen to you and then
tell you things you had never conceived
of before and stuff like that so I had a
good time in college until they kicked
me out
at what point did you start looking at
the military as a legitimate option for
you
ah not until I was about to graduate and
back in the good old days my dad worked
he was a New Yorker New Yorker New
Yorker but he got a job in Reading
Pennsylvania
and it was a shock to all of us I didn't
want to leave the school I was in and I
was going to Pro girls so this is back
in high school yeah yeah I was two years
into Chaminade High School in Long
Island which is by entrance exams and
tuition and and I I liked it there I was
doing a little bit better a little bit
better but uh I didn't want to leave and
he came home and said he'd been offered
a job in Reading Pennsylvania where is
that
we were New Yorkers and New Yorkers I
can do the accent too and of course when
you get to Pennsylvania the kids make
endless fun of you because of your
accent and stuff but at any rate um
where was I in this uh we're just trying
to figure out at what point did you yeah
think that military might be an option I
could go downtown reading and go up the
fires fire tower
staircase and plop in the uh in the
chair in my dad's office
and he said so what are you gonna do
you're going to graduate here and I said
well I don't know he said the uh
have you considered maybe the government
would teach you how to fly in one of the
services and I ah they don't take guys
like me he said they surely do
2020s and uh
good shape nothing wrong with him
so I applied to the Navy guy and he uh
he was an embarrassment uh overweight
feet up on the desk
um
didn't seem to care about anything I
filled out all his paperwork and he
never got back to me went to the Air
Force guy and he was close to his uh his
quota probably
he drove me around oh yeah dude you have
to go here and fill out these pal I'll
help you fill out the form and so so and
the Air Force took me so
but uh the uh
what was the question well that that was
the question the question was how did
you first get my dad my dad said see if
you can learn how to fly and he didn't
know how to fly so did they have like a
contract that made you a pilot was that
part of the enlistment process
um they they when they said we like
everything you do now you have to fill
out a uh um a preference sheet and you
can put whatever you like in there we
suggest this list of stuff over here
and then you make them one two and three
choices
I said well I want to be a pilot because
that's what I'm doing this whole thing
for he said well most people put in
navigator for a second and then
something like
I don't know auxiliary Aviation or
something like that I said well that's
not why I'm here so I put pilot pilot
pilot one two three
funny thing too the B-52 Squadron I was
later in was a guy from my college class
and I said Danny what are you doing here
as a navigator he said well they told me
put pilot first Navigators second and I
said you don't wear glasses or anything
he said well that's what they took me as
I said well I didn't want to rub it in
so I just didn't let it alone so what
was your indoctrination to the Air Force
then I went to their OCS in uh in uh
San Antonio it's not at Lackland it's I
think they call it the Medina Base it's
nearby
and went through that that's three
months was it was it a shock to your
system were you wondering why the hell
you did this well I was fortunate there
were several uh enlisted previous
enlisted guys there and I I thought they
know the ropes do whatever they do so
that's what I did and I said and then
they said if you play a musical
instrument put your name on this list
and I said no don't guy told me don't
volunteer for anything before I went in
so I found out the the guy was running
this thing he loves to have live music
for any parades that he has and if you
can play a musical get your name on it I
did
so what instrument did you play I played
the trumpet and cornet I played baritone
I can play alto horn or French horn or
any of those
but I dropped that you know for a long
time midlife I'm back into it now anyway
you got out of everything
you straightened up your uh your your
digs and your bed and whatnot and uh
when the Saturday morning inspection
happened we had rehearsal and that was
they if you will all knew that so so
this is 19 what 1963. no no uh 65.
January 65 because see I graduated
I graduated in August because I was
having too much fun that by that point
in in college I found this you ought to
take that professor's history course
he's really interesting and you should
take comparative economic systems
because you should do that and I didn't
have enough
credits I had two if you needed 150 I
had 175 but you don't have enough in
your major or in your minor you had you
took that course and you got the good
grading and at any rate so I wound up
graduating in August
but
um
so it's 1965 so you're starting to hear
about Vietnam you guys must be talking
about no no no because that happened in
January of
five yeah in summer of 64. I worked
through college at a small Summer Stock
Playhouse because I was in the drama
club in college and you meet the sky and
meet that guy and so forth and uh all
very legitimate if you will good people
not these sorts of flaky dumb people
that you might think of when you think
of theater sort of people you know and I
had a mentor by this point a guy from
New York was old enough to be my father
and he said um when you uh graduate what
are you going to do I said well I don't
know I have this paperwork can to go to
the Air Force to fly and and stuff and
uh he said they were looking for a guy
like you at a theater in Baltimore that
I am going to he said should I mention
you to them and I
well I'm okay
so he called me in about a week or so
and he said they want 15 minutes of
drama and 50 minutes of com of Comedy if
you can do that they want to talk to you
so I went to a woman in the in the
summer stock company
and Grace Chapman wonderful woman and I
said can you help me and she did I said
oh I'm going to do it like this and she
no no no we're going to do this way and
so forth
so uh
rehearsed it with her I have to memorize
everything of course and did all that
and went down to Baltimore
stood up on the stage lights and they
got what a few people are watching you
to judge you the two bosses they're
thinking of giving you some kind of a
role or no they they had a program there
with the you actually worked as it were
in the in the union deal uh the actors
Union is called Actors Equity you work
as a local jobber and it's called doing
what what's your job as well
they've got you they've got you by the
short hairs as they say and uh
that you'll you will get roles
maybe a minor maybe just a walk-on for
this one and maybe something serious I
got one very nice roll out of it I was
the uh Elder son in Galileo the by Berto
Ric it was a notable European communist
but a good director there for that John
Marley the guy who a lot of people he
was a Workhorse
Hollywood movie actor he uh he was the
guy in bed with a horse
during the first Godfather that was John
Marley and a nice man as well
anyway uh so wait so this was in the
summertime you were doing this summer
stock
in a barn believe it or not in
Pennsylvania and then Jerry Richards was
a New York guy old enough to be my dad
said he was going to this Equity company
in Baltimore it was relatively new
called Center Stage it's still active
today and was I interested did you have
another thing in mind and I went back
and I said to my mother I've been
passing I was thinking about this she
said do what you have to do all right
so uh
I hitchhiked once again to Baltimore to
Baltimore how long did you stay in
Baltimore for
only until uh I got a big fat envelope
in the mail from DOD and and it said we
will teach you to fly if you want to and
of course the draft was there and I had
already called the draft board and I
said
where am I and they said oh we can't
tell you by the law but I'll tell you
this you're close to the front of the
drawer I remember that very well and I
thought I got to do something about this
I wonder what to do about this and I I
went to a fellow guy was in the same
position I was in the company
said well I don't know what to do and he
said do what I did tell him you like
boys not girls
I said that's not true he said it's not
true with me either but it got me ready
to go sit on the bench over there and
they ask you do you really like boys
rather than girls and and he said I just
said that's right I do and that was the
end of that and I got off I thought oh
boy that may be good advice some ways
but I thought somewhere down the road
somebody's going to drag that out 40
years from now and and so forth I didn't
want to do that then lo and behold I get
this big fat envelope in mail I go to
Jerry Richards my mentor I said what
should I do he said uh he was a combat
veteran of World War II uh a dog face
Soldier had funny stories to tell about
being on a line of March hot sweaty and
like an Italian farmer going by with a
wooden tank on a little wagon
pulled by a horse
and the
second lieutenant or whoever he was said
stay away from that tank we all knew it
was full of wine
or grape juice anyway and he said we got
two-thirds of the line through there and
saw me boom boom boom that was it that
everything collapsed anyway super nice
guy and uh what I went to Jerry and I
said what should I do about this and he
said well you always come back to this
but you never get another chance to do
that so so I signed on the dotted line
and I went to went into the Air Force
I like the 2nd of January
1975. 1965.
60 yeah
that's right 65. so so yeah so that
early part of Vietnam because I always
think in a way the news kind of worked
it was that battle the I drank Valley in
1965 where really hit the news and there
was casualties and it seemed like the
escalation really kind of started yeah
um
so you get done with the the officer
candidate school and then is that you
get you get your slot to flight school
right and uh that was at Webb Air Force
Base in West Texas at Big Spring Texas
uh
pretty much of a Barren place just east
of the big big oil fields but there were
plenty of oil wells around where I was
around Big Spring but the big oil fields
around Midland and uh
Odessa Texas
Permian Basin it's called
and there had been at least one crash at
Big Spring Texas they made a very big
deal out of them rightly so the guy was
confused about stars and oil fields
every every drilling if not their
drilling rig but every pumping deal has
its own light bulb on it and he got
confused and rolled over
yeah so really a shame but I learned to
fly there and uh then went to the how
was flight school
it was tough for me at first because I
didn't know a wing from a tail uh an
aileron from an elevator or anything and
about half those guys had private
licenses at least half of them had
private licenses and uh and a couple of
them had commercial multi-engines out
there and just walking through the thing
and but I was slow to get going but when
I got into the second half which was the
t-38 at that time uh I did very well but
uh
but it's like a baseball trying baseball
player trying to bring his average up
second half of the Season you know
so your grade point average is uh was it
was a problem for me and
and I wound up getting a B-52 assignment
uh my roommates got c-130s which was a
very desirable deal if you didn't want
to get shot at turned out to be very
foolish
and because you in C-130 you got shot at
in the Vietnam War and one of my
roommates got uh Air Defense command
f-104
which was considered to be creme de la
crème until I got assigned to the F4
But first you had to do your B-52 time
right the G model in Rome New York with
a wonderful place wonderful people there
I liked everything about it except
sitting alert awful
so this is now what 1966 or so yeah
that's right and you're assigned to the
B-52 uh Squadron in Rome New York yeah
very heavily decorated squadron from
World War II I can't remember the number
488 or something like that Eighth Air
Force
um I had a first guy they put me with
was a
a guy of shorter stature and I think he
had a problem about that and I was six
feet tall and whatnot and all the way
down to him saying I said to that's not
so he said it is so and you shut up
because I'm a major and you're just a
goddamn first lieutenant whoa okay but
at any rate he fired me so to speak
basically he didn't want to fly with me
anymore because I was
I may have made better Landings than he
did because the next guy I got was a
family man and we got along like
brothers and it was crazy so the one
lead pilot or whatever is he called the
lead pilot the major yeah he didn't like
flying with you right well he didn't
like your attitude or something and you
didn't like my attitude either so he got
rid of you right but then you just moved
to another guy yeah well they gave me
another game you don't have any choice
about it but we we got a long one just
had fun every day and and what's the
deal with sitting alert
well they did it uh two different ways
at Rome New York where I was uh they had
eight airplanes on alert at any one time
um all the airplanes that I was on had
two hound dog stand-off missiles with
Thermo nuclear weapons in them there the
mark 28 at that time I don't think it's
classified anymore
but the highest yield on those
single Warhead purr and it was a pop on
me
um and then four thermonuclear weapons
in the Bombay and then four Quail decoy
missiles in the Bombay
and uh the targets for the ones I was on
well I was on a mission that was
downtown Moscow believe it or not and
and land in Turkey I think all of the
ones I was on were land in Turkey
because you're out of fuel by then you
refueled south of Iceland
and then went in and then turned
straight South
and landed on pretty much on an
abandoned Airfield in central turkey
who were instructed to get fuel by Jerry
Cann
this is silly and we knew it
the Jerry Ken was not enough he had
eight j-57s on a B-52 and the H model
had modified j57s that were fan jet
engines
but it was silly you'd never forget
enough fuel to refuel the thing to fly
it anywhere so I mean was that just
because once you flew over Moscow and
dropped nuclear weapons it wouldn't
really matter where you get what was the
pretty much because you're assuming that
the world would be a conflagration and
uh would be pretty much of a mess but at
that point you would truly a
thermonuclear war would have
finished by that time I guess and
everything would be
powerful mass and are you sitting
like are the are the weapons loaded on
the aircraft just sitting there
absolutely positively with an armed
guard on every airplane
walking around underneath
every airplane 24 hours a day was there
any events that would heighten your
Readiness they would have practice
alerts that could happen at any time the
um
uh
the sac World Strategic Air Command
worldwide would call an alert in every
Sac base on the planet even in obscure
places would
and do what they were told to do and
they basically had three commands one to
man the airplanes and start them
stay in place second start the airplanes
and taxi down the runway just
from motivate the flying machines and
third would be a real launch actually
there were two kinds of launches
launched to a
holding Point short of total commitment
or
four total commitment from minute one
so
obviously the third and fourth never
happened with me and
they would
the alert was at Rome New York at
Griffis Air Force Base orange that's
where I was and wonderful people there
too was seven days you had seven days on
and the rules were half your time on
alert you had free
but it didn't really work out that way
because you didn't get away from the
base until in this case Thursday you
know 12 o'clock or something like that
and you lost half the day and then they
would schedule you for
a flight maybe Monday
night at 8 pm so Monday was sort of gone
because you had to sleep because you
were going to fly for 12 hours you took
off at 8 pm you're going to land at
eight o'clock Tuesday morning all those
missions those training missions were
eight hours
and but I didn't training missions were
sort of fun and interesting I spent a
lot of time with my hands in my lap but
nevertheless they're interesting and you
went all over the United States all over
the United States doing those things you
know and a lot of them were at low level
because that's what you would do in the
case of a nuclear war oh it's a
low-level attack oh yes well the B-52s
were all
um
assigned low altitude like how low 200
feet
yeah just get underneath radar right
yeah as low as you want to go is what I
was told that I said how I said this is
a poker deck route and this is published
at 400 feet how low are we going to
talking about here if we have actually
do have a war right as long as you want
to go
said one point that you have charts that
were accurate accurate and how it
classified obviously but I said to one
of the the guys who worked in the vault
you had to do Target study while you
were on alert and I said you show
telephone poles here Here I Am the
co-pilot
looking for the next turn
can I count those telephone poles
yes you can whoa they were all done by
you too or by satellite I think the
satellites were just starting at that
time
so I said so it would be the 28th
telephone pole I can turn left to zero
three zero
yep anyway so you uh what was the
question where the heck were we well
it's very interesting to hear like sort
of what your status was yeah as a pilot
and I I actually asked you what level of
alert what's the highest level of alert
you are because obviously you missed the
Cuban Missile Crisis that's right
because I'm sure that would have been a
very high alert maybe they even do you
think they got Airborne for that I don't
think so I don't think so I don't
remember ever asking anybody I don't but
I don't think that that happened no and
that had to be a little bit of a strange
uh uh weight on your shoulders to think
about especially with your background
with your English teacher that didn't
like the atomic bombs dropped on Japan
right and here you are with a mission
tasking that if you get this mission
You're Gonna Fly and annihilate you know
basically the world well I have a little
bit of a funny story about about exactly
here that turns into a funny story I
like that in the G and the H we had the
Gunner up front and the gun the guns
that were in the tail so these are the g
h models of the B-52 right and up to
that the Gunner Road in the tail and uh
if he were to bail out he would jettison
his turret which weighed something like
2 000 pounds everything his ammunition
and his and his 50 calibers and
everything's short of the seat he sat on
a chemical toilet back there
incidentally but then he would bail out
he did not have an injection seat just
it was right in front of his toes and he
just stepped forward or leaned forward
now he went with a conventional
parachute anyway
um
the uh the Gunner with and the G and the
H models up front in the cockpit
Arrangement is different in the G and
the H than it was in the earlier up to
the F model B-52 the G's no longer exist
they they went with the Strategic arms
limitation treaty the G's got pictures
of them getting their wings cut off that
they took Airborne pictures of all that
so
but at any rate the g e h internally are
the same in the in the the ECM officer
and the Gunner ride facing backwards
and uh
uh no no I was gonna oh yeah so on your
charts when you do your
first day of alert Target study it's the
same charts every time
Gunners he's sitting across the tables
and I said what oh you have l p b n that
means something and
Eve e35 that means something across the
route of flight
and they said lpbo
it's in the same lettering stencil same
ink same everything
I said what's lpbo he said last point of
bailout
I said that's over Finland he said
exactly right I'm not going to anybody's
nuclear war I'm leaving over Finland I'm
taking the seat pack with me with the 22
rifle the sleeping bag and everything
I'm out of here
but it never happened
he was he was a E6 enlisted guy and nice
family man and everything else but I'm
not going to nuclear worry nuts so how
long did you do this job for a year well
including the the rag if you will in in
Merced California year and a half
but then I got the big fat envelope that
said
here is your inter-service transfer if
you want to do this you you can do and
that's what you had applied for right
and why did you try and do an inner
service transfer to the Navy because I
didn't want two two sides and there's
popping your peas again there
I didn't want to sit alert anymore
I didn't like riding around with my
hands in my lap
and going way back and I had this idea
in the back of my head
my first cross country and the t-37 out
of Webb Air Force Base we stopped
somewhere I can't remember
and there were two Navy guys there
wearing golf shirts underneath there
flight suits and
through the open door there were two a4s
parked out there and they said something
like USS Independence or USS who knows
for sale everyone was on I thought isn't
that hot stuff
these guys can go to see with those
things and go I don't know anywhere they
want
that's hot and then I saw the back of a
proceedings magazine
proceedings used to be magazine size
then it became smaller format
but it showed an A4 looking over the A4
shoulder like the wingman or something
like that looking over and he's on short
final for her carrier and I thought
that's hot
so that did it and it wasn't hard to put
in that Energy Service transfer it was
pretty straightforward
they bounced it back at me so oh no I
didn't even formats wrong has to be this
way in that way and have to do that and
that's fine well what do you want us to
do I said well you tell me it's wrong I
did it according to what was in the
Publications Library
you do it
I said well I guess we have to and they
did and
then I signed everything a second time
and then the way it went and you got
straight into the pilot pipeline
well no I was you know when you're a
military officer you are an officer of
the United States you're not an Air
Force officer or a Navy officer or even
an officer of the there's a land survey
and mapping service they have military
uniforms you are an officer of the
United States
so it isn't like you change services you
change uniforms and you change
terminology and you change verbiage
and the name of your grade changes from
first lieutenant to Lieutenant Junior
great but
um
they can put you anywhere they want you
can be a seal who's a lieutenant
commander and they can say guess what we
want you in the embassy in Tunisia and
it's only going to be six months but
you'll be wearing civilian clothes and
you'll be responsible for the thus and
so on us and so on that can do that
because remember you're appointed by the
president of the United States
you're going to serve in that capacity
but so that's what happens with an inner
service transfer and I was told that
when they they you make the transfer
it's basically a
long table meeting of
senior service I'll I have a doc who
wants to come over to the Air Force and
you have a a junior Lieutenant who wants
to go Navy I'll swap you for those two
and okay that's fine let me do that and
so forth and so forth and that's the way
it's done but every six months or
something like that and it probably goes
on right now I don't know but but you
ended up with the pilot slot somehow
yeah well I had orders to King to uh
Kingsville Corpus Christi and wound up
standing in a guy's office nice guy with
the lieutenant commander
a few of the parking ramp with S2s
stoofs parked behind him piston engine
anti-submarine airplanes it was a
training facility for them
and a couple of Lieutenant commanders
standing over here and me standing
right here in front of his desk and he
said what are we going to do with you I
said I I don't know I just have these
orders I said you flew Jets I said yeah
sure well then we send you to Kingsville
what should we do with him what happens
if he can't get aboard I thought I will
get aboard
so what's Kingsville
uh Kingsville to Advanced Training bases
I think there is Beeville still active
people's clothes still can do yeah and
Kingsville is bigger than ever and the
Navy Advance at that time they were f9s
there
and I went over to Kingsville and
introduced myself and dropped my orders
on the table and so to speak and all
very nice and looked out the window
and they had these ancient airplanes f9s
cream war vintage oh boy
of what
ancient equipment here there was more
fun to fly than you can imagine you put
the power up all the way and leave it
there and it's like your brother's mg
with a little four-cylinder engine in it
was so much fun to drive underpowered
same way fun fun fun to fly it was truly
a flying airplane with a with a wing
airfoil wing and everything else you fly
to get into the Phantom and you find no
this is a machine now now at this point
you're hearing about Vietnam Vietnam's
now is 1911 1967 yeah so now you know
what you're in the pipeline your goal is
to be a fighter pilot you know what that
pipeline ends up in Vietnam yeah so your
detailer calls you on the whole phone in
the boq and I was I think I was
Lieutenant by this point maybe not
senior Lieutenant Junior grade anyway I
have two rooms and um and private bath
and and you were in Kingsville in those
big solid boqs there very nice and why
not but when you took a shower the the
water was so bad the ground worn and it
smelled like ancient sauerkraut remember
that it's awful at any rate
um
hey Tommy you got a phone call it's my
detailer again he said Tom we really
want you in the A6 that's just for you
same as the B-52 you have experience
with offsets and everything else it's
going to be perfect
I said I don't want that Bob you know
that
call me back next
series of phone calls
the last one was the same thing Tom you
perfect for the A6 by now you probably
looked around talked around about it
that's a heck of an airplane yeah I know
Bob I still won't fly the F4 okay
let me let me think about it in about a
week later a guy called me and said you
have hoarders and up there at admin and
Big Spring at that I'm sorry Kingsville
at that time
was nowhere land and I did not have a
car
sit it's up at the other end of the main
drag that parallel hanger area
I said well first of all I Said Fred
what am I orders say I wouldn't look at
them it's none of my business oh
yeah gentlemen don't read each other's
well don't walk up there and here and I
had F4 the mirror so
and the F4 what year did F4 come out
what year was that I think the first
prototype flew in 58. is that right that
sounds about right just just real quick
all right so you're you go through all
Air Force training you're a B-52 guy and
then you CQ and the F9
yeah what was that like
I mean they're worried that you can't
even get a board right yeah yeah what
was that like well I guess my fclp was
okay
um and uh when I first time out fclp I
think this is boring me I can do this
and so forth and the guy comes back and
he says well you were listening you were
listening you were that's amazing how do
you know that and so forth and that's
lsos they grade you accurately and their
Club
diagnosis I was in LSL oh okay they it's
hard to get into their club right and
and you can't really dispute what they
tell you and after every
SC Landing he's in your ready room turn
well you started out high and and so
forth and so forth so you guys have now
both thrown I I was wondering if I
missed something but the term get aboard
what does this mean expand on it oh
there are guys I guess who just say are
you crazy I'm not going to do that I
thought I didn't realize you had to do
that or I guess that's what happens or
they're just so what it used to be
called the guy's a plumber and he can't
do it uh so get aboard means you
actually qualify in the aircraft yeah
get aboard is just a language for can
you land on the ship right and uh okay I
didn't know that's what I was missing
yeah and it's hard it's just it's it's
the phrase of hey is this guy gonna be
able to get a board meaning any land is
playing on the boat yeah right what
happens I think every now and then is
you got guys go through the whole
pipeline Kerry calls is the last thing
you do in training right traditionally
and you could be great at all these
things but if you can't get a board
you're no good to the Navy that's
because we land on boats uh and so yeah
we're sending you to p3s or yeah and
Fighters exactly so so is that what
happens you get sent to p3s you get I
mean now you get sent to you know p3s
you go to
um helicopters if you can't get a board
in a jet they're going to send you to
some other non-tactical platform that's
true
I I I've been talking about this lately
it seems like
there's certain skill sets that people
some people just can't get through like
a like for instance when I was going
through SEAL training
I I would say about one out of every
hundred guys
they're they're just they're just not
going to be able to shoot a pistol well
and they might actually not make it
through the training because they can't
shoot a pistol they might be an athlete
they might be great at everything they
might be smart they can't shoot a pistol
uh Close Quarters combat there's a bunch
of strict little things that you have to
follow
and some people I think that number's
about four out of every hundred this is
in in in basic SEAL training or seal
qualification training that they're just
not gonna get it they're just there's
not bad people
they do a lot of other things well but
they just can't do that thing and it
sounds like occasionally someone that
can fly a plane someone that can land it
on the Airfield someone that can do the
turns they need to do in the sky someone
that understands the Dynamics of it but
they can't get aboard they can't land on
that aircraft carrier right and then it
doesn't matter that's true no it does
matter because
um uh we even you were a Top Gun guy but
I was a an instructor at Meridian at the
end of my career
and I don't remember exactly how or what
but the guy said to me and the
friendliest collegial way you know if
your students can't cut it it's not
their fault it's your fault because if
this guy is not uh
uh the sort of guy we want for tail hook
we'll find a place for him and he'll be
valuable to the Navy so in the Air Force
is the other way around it's always felt
to me like they were trying to get rid
of you
they were always rotten to you except
for one guy who wound up being a I think
I put this in my list of stuff he wound
up being a four-star general in nato in
Europe he I maybe was personal uh
self-esteem or self-confidence or
something like that he was very quiet
instructive and he's already t-38s and
an Air Force Advanced very laid back
he'd say Tom come left a little bit more
or Tom let me show you and he did that
was in his lesson and he wouldn't talk
to me for 10 minutes and stuff like that
but but not because he didn't want to
just let you go until you made him no no
no let me show you something and stuff
like that so I bet about that anyway
they always acted like they wanted to
get ready or worse in the Navy if the
kid doesn't make it he's been qualified
By Us in 16 different ways If he if he
quits or
wants to quit it's your fault not his
and so forth we'll find a place for him
and hilo's and you have two guys there
and stuff like that
so uh where the heck where are we so so
then so then you do get your orders you
get your F4 or others and I guess I
kicked this whole uh tangent off just by
the F4 at the time was just like the
ultimate beast the monster yeah that's
what I always called it and then uh I I
want to mirror
and I remember this like it was
yesterday
check in do all that I'm going to find a
place in the boq forget it I had no
chance Tom so I had to go find a place
to live off base and whatnot but at any
rate uh vf121 was the F4 rag at that
time and was the Eastward end of the
runway there and uh
I uh that a couple of steps going
through a narrow gate that was always
open and an F4 looking you're looking at
the tail up the pipes of this thing and
I thought oh my God I forgot how to
think this is a monster I forgot and
they had Marines working on them because
they were going to denying our true lie
to get shot
full of holes and eventually abandoned
over over there and they took The Radars
out and put lead noses in them at that
place and basically went over the whole
thing and they had Marine Marines Max
working on them there but I thought oh
my oh look at that thing and so that's
that's the thing and then I walked to
the end of the hangar and and uh
there are two f4s taking the runaway and
you vf-121 at that time was at that end
of the East End of the runway and 99 of
the time of America took off to the West
and two f4s rolled out on the runway it
was night and early morning low Coastal
clouds and fog just like here
at this is at Miramar and uh
they ran up
and then they rolled
and they firewalled and they went to
burn her
and then they disappeared into the Mist
I thought oh my God I am in over my head
but you learned to do it and get good at
it I got pretty good at it although you
know it's the thing about lsos since
you're here so the lso is the greater
basically but the landing signal officer
you grade every every Landing that's
right okay and you have to call your
meatball and state for every Landing VFR
IFR or anything else and he's the guy
when you look up and they say one Peak
is worth ten thousand scans scanning
your panel
instrument flying is something that's
hard to understand if you haven't done
it you cannot make a mistake or you're
going to be killed and wrecked the
airplane no mistakes allowed and I
genuine IFR and especially carrier IFR
but uh he's the guy who says to you uh
you say uh 2400 Clara and he says to you
that means I don't see the meatball and
really you can't see the deck either and
he says to you
you're looking great babe keep it coming
and you just have to trust what he's
saying right because you can't see
visually because of fog or whatever well
one second later or maybe a half second
later you see the deck and then you're
bored uh he'll say that to you
at a half mile the radar controller says
half mile call the ball or execute a
wave off
and you take a second Peak and nothing
there you see a white glow from the deck
but if you're on Center Line and on
glide slope you're going to be okay just
he's tracking that via radar or he's
yeah because he can't see you either
right yeah what they the ship does it's
different now I think but it's it's
essentially sort of the same you have a
the F4 had a radar reflector on the nose
gear and the ships track while scan
radar would lock onto that receiver
otherwise it might lock onto the wingtip
and that will keep you on you if you
flying accurately the way you're
supposed everything will be when you
break out you'll be on Center Line on
glide slope of the center of meatball
and basically don't don't with a
fuel in black oil ship constellation was
a Black America before it they were both
black oil ships
that have a stacked gas problem but
actually with a nuclear-powered carrier
you have the burble that comes around
the wind coming around the island I'm
told you can feel that too but with a
with a fossil powered ship you had a lot
of burble that so you're hitting
turbulence basically right there yeah a
tenth of a mile from touchdown yeah and
one time I had my mask loose and you
could smell it
my mask wasn't tight enough what would
you do you remember your first Carrier
Landing yeah I do how'd it go
I thought that was pretty great that's
that's all I remember I remember being
on the Catapult though on it was
Randolph with hydraulic cats it was one
of the only ships left with hydraulic
acid all been converted to steam when
they when they put the angled deck on
them I mean these old Essex uh and
Yorktown class ships they put Steam
catapults in them but they put some of
them they put hydraulic hats and
Randolph was still with a wonderful
clean well-run ship I thought what a
little I know the captain was very
friendly to me because I was an oddball
I was a coming across Air Force officer
he had been told come on up and
bridgeline so it was very nice at any
rate
um sitting there
getting ready to get on the hydraulic
cats on Randolph I remember thinking to
myself I don't have to be doing this
I remember thinking if I say I don't
want to do this
they'll stop right now
I must be crazy
I did it boom but without your first cat
launch yeah and they told you over and
over again these are hydraulic hats
Bob said you're
in pal and instructor
he said now
make sure you're all the way back make
sure you got your elbow locked because
it's a hell of a bang and you get on
your first 15 20 feet you get 80 percent
of your acceleration right up front and
then you sort of just trundle down the
rest of the way
so I was ready boy I had all the way
back in the seat head back and elbow
locked I didn't think about my knees
when that thing went off my knees were
up here somewhere
but the F9 I think the fa-18 is the same
way you can take the shot hands off and
then grab the stick as soon as you're
out over the water and
so I still had my hand on the pole but I
had to get my knees back down
is the hydraulic harder to launch than
the steam because the steam is more
gradual buildup or something yeah the
steam is smoother and it's a continuous
uh flow and I guess the new electric
cats are that way as well they're
supposed to be even better I guess I
don't know how there would be but
I guess there would be now this is the
time like Dan Peterson you guys are
working like almost getting in this
air-to-air combat where you're training
at a level that really you hadn't
trained before or or the pilots hadn't
been training this way where we're going
hard against each other all the time uh
yes and no in that that was the
beginning of the I said in my talking to
Dave via email I said my only claim to
fame here being unusual if you will is
the fact that I was there when what
became Top Gun started I was there it's
Sam Leeds who's in Dan Peterson's book
came into various ready rooms and vf121
had about three or four of them I can't
even remember because it took the whole
hanger and they came in there and said
we're going to do this oh a lot of f4s
and some f8s too were getting shot down
by mig-17s mostly but our ra5cs are
getting shot and down by mig-21s because
they make 21.
the ra5c would be cruising at say 600
knots taking pictures or going to his
next spot to take pictures in the mig-21
would come downhill from 30 35
000 at 1.2 1.4 or something like that
and launch a Soviet
what was the B model they had stolen
from us a Sidewinder and shoot down the
ra5c that was a big deal don't let your
RF a5c if you're the s i was lots of
times if you're the escort of the rf5
scene don't let him get you have to keep
looking back and up there and be
prepared to turn into him for a head-on
with a sparrow
but at any rate
um what was the question well I'm just
trying to gather that uh eventually what
I want to know is how well prepared you
were when you went on deployment
from a pilot so like I was in the SEAL
Teams we would shoot so many rounds
through our guns yeah we would do so
many immediate ax drills we would do so
many uh drills and so much training yeah
that by the time we went overseas I felt
really good yeah I felt really good and
I I'm trying to figure out where you
guys would feel the first time you get
on your first combat mission
well there's nothing quite like getting
shot at the first time you do remember
that yeah but I remember the time they
they had some sort of an exercise where
we flew down the coast and back up again
and maybe went up as high as high and
oil and and or more the seaport the high
fall once at the mouth of the river up
there and back and got a board and came
aboard big exercise I remember looking
out over northern part of South Vietnam
and over into Laos and all that red I
thought holy smoke ever that's for real
it's only every one and every six but
you're not quite ready for that and the
first time you actually see it going by
it makes you an older man immediately I
think so
um
so you're but you're training to get
ready to get over there there's no idea
dog fighting are you oh yeah oh yes yeah
one-on-ones that's what you did in your
training you left Miramar went out over
the water and the standard deal was the
your
flight leader you're the wingman he
kisses you off you both turn 30 degrees
away
and you proceed until one guy turns in
you can turn in immediately or you can
wait if you're the younger guy you wait
until the older guy
finally turns in because he can't see
you anymore you can barely see him and
you know his eyeballs
are not as good as yours but you turn in
and make a head on it and then you can
see his wings Flash and he sees your
wings Flash and you make a head-on pass
but that's not the way it is in combat
when you get into a combat situation
well statistically it doesn't matter
whether it's World War One Korea
or the Vietnam War the guys who got shot
down the guys who didn't see it coming
it's like
99 of them one guy got shot down let's
say he said yeah he got it on me and he
pulled inside and he unloaded and he got
me but that's the exception and moreover
95 percent of the airplane shot down I
popped a pee there in in Vietnam
uh were with triple A not with Sam's
everybody you know samsis and Sam's that
but no When You're vulnerable and
relatively close to the ground
um that's when they they got you
especially when you could see it going
by you were in in the envelope if you
would and that's just like a matter of
chance in a way that's right
well better tactics there are better
tactics and poor tactics and I think I
wrote In
had my monograph there a guy said to me
way back
in Kingsville I teach you to let it roll
off on a wing let the nose fall acquire
the target
adjust a little bit and now you were
watching the altimeter and so forth
and this is polony I want to hit the
target I want to put them right in the
hole there's some pull down up invert
pull down some Ros think you're crazy
the first time they are in the back when
you do this pull down as steep as
possible
well more than 30 degrees you better how
about 60 or 70 degrees the steeper you
are the safer you are
the faster you are the better you are
and then I think I wrote in here is
there any compromise when you go to when
you go to come out of that dive and turn
the air airplane back up towards nothing
because they've been through all that at
Pax River
say the the flight test in the book The
Manual that you have either the the
natops manual is what's the flight
manual for Pilots or the tactics manual
has all these tables in there and you
can say if I get out and Smith let's say
an 80 degrees angle Bank dive and I get
out at 6 000 feet I'll still be well
clear I have 1500 feet of of to clear if
I pull six and a half G's to get out if
I pull seven I'm I'm even better off but
you lose power when you do that you I'm
sorry you lose air speed when you do
that so you've pulled pull the G's
you'll you're safe a lot of you guys
would not do that though but you would
did you train this way before going to
Vietnam did you know that the high angle
attack was better
no where you figured out when you got
there no I figured it out in Arizona
okay going on there that those targets
there that they have I guess in the east
coast they have them all over the place
too in rural places it's a huge plowed
area and plowed in a in a circle and
you've got they have two towers
wooden Towers on on 12 o'clock at nine
o'clock three o'clock and uh they talk
to each other and they they tell you
where your hit was on there and a white
thing in the center
um and they tell you you know your bomb
but God told me if you want to be safe
be steeper be faster I said that's for
me and then I saw this picture sort of
famous and you've probably seen it
um of an airplane diving on a Japanese
aircraft carrier at Midway
and the guy is 89 degrees
that is for me that's why I'm going to
do it so Roland pulling your nose down
then you get your dive right there
because your nose wants to come up the
faster you go in an airplane whether
it's a Piper Cub or an F4 or fa-18 your
nose wants to rise as you build air air
speed is just aerodynamics so get the
nose down there right now and then you
can do whatever you want you have four
you could pull powered idle at 500 and
it would hold five I don't know what
they do and after 18s but anyway pull
the power to idle at 500 almost no
matter what you dive angle was
what does that mean pull power to idle
at 500 what does that mean just pull the
throttles all the way back to idle and
it would hold 500 knots it wouldn't
increase your speed to something right I
don't know why it's just they discovered
it no doubt after they were actually
flying the airplane
but if you go 550 it'll hold that so a
lot of guys would say 500 is fast enough
for me I've got to pull out of this but
I said belong you look on the charts you
can get out easy they wouldn't do it but
I said steeper's better so if it's
because the guy in the back says you
know we were 560 knots tonight yeah
that's fine that's I like that okay I
never had any holes I got scared a
couple of times well yeah got warned I
had a load go off right there that gave
me
you have a new picture taken with an old
style flash buffing and spots and it
gave me spots in front of my eyes that
was that close but no holes I never did
I know guys that came back with a hole
about as big as a 45
caliber bullet in the bottom of the
airplane but
not me we had
leadership in the Squadron I was in that
I kept going back to reading your book
about how this guy Opera rural Gardener
the way he operated he was a former
underwater demolition team guy right and
and so how did he operate he was very
laid back very quiet about everything
and uh
we get after him about sharks for
instance and he said nah he's the Sharks
don't bother you but barracudas
sometimes do they're curious and they'll
come right up to you and wonder what the
heck you're doing and what you are
it ain't right that sort of thing and he
was the guy who would do the classic
Navy routine if you will Tom can you
help me with this as opposed to Tom get
that done rather can you help me with
that so
it's funny in leadership terms if if you
say to a guy can you help me with this
he may not really want to do it but the
way you phrase it makes you want to help
him if he says do that or else and you
don't want to do it because you are 100.
it's your style
but it's effective
um in leadership terms very effective to
to use the old Navy way of doing things
like that I don't know how the Marine
Corps operates but uh
I had a pal who got killed in Vietnam uh
who's told me I will be a Marine General
he got killed being aggressive I think
based upon what I heard about what what
happened with him but at any rate
um uh you I just wondered how the Marine
Corps operates when the guy doesn't want
to really do that but he would if you
would just asked him as opposed to
saying do it or else well having worked
with uh all kinds of leaders in the Army
Navy Air Force and Marines uh the good
leaders in all those organizations are
the type that say hey I need some help
with this hey what do you think how do
you think about this stuff and across
the board and then you take this into
the civilian sector as well the ones
that bark orders and yell at people and
say you need to do this right now
because I'm ordering you to do it
they're they're they're not ever
considered to be good leaders but let's
by and large the Air Force Style
no exaggeration I maybe my experience in
the Air Force wasn't broad enough but by
and large that's what they do there what
bark orders yeah yeah I think the
internet maybe the origin having read
his autobiography you know he didn't
write it himself really really but
fairlessly talking about the way he
operated in England in World War II and
do it or else yeah well wait a minute
yeah well there's a whole there's a
whole
thing to talk about there you know this
idea of the authoritarian people certain
people have an authoritarian mindset
they're attracted to the authoritarian
mindset and the when they look at the
military when they're 10 years old or 17
years old or 20 years old they look at
the military and they're they're very
excited about it because they think oh
there's a place where if I have rank
people have to respect me they have to
listen to me and so the military
actually attracts these type of people
and most of the time
they they they kind of become not the
best leaders and they usually don't make
it very far because they piss people off
and and whatever occasionally you'll
have someone that gets put in the right
circumstances and despite the fact that
they're a tyrannical leader they're
still able to advance and you know
Curtis LeMay is probably a good example
of that you know here he was in charge
of bombing Europe and he puts together
plans like hey this is what we're doing
and it was an extreme situation and it
ended up working and then he gets you
know his his yeah but exactly in his
autobiography he says that I had no
choice but to to begin to ascertain that
we had to do it that way or else we
wouldn't do it at all yeah yeah so so it
can happen but even I mean like I said
I've worked with Air Force I've worked
with navy I've worked with the Marine
Corps obviously I've worked with the
Navy and the and the good leaders in all
of them are not tyrannical at all now
are there situations that you can get
into where it's like hey we gotta this
is what we're doing occasionally that
happens yeah uh but it doesn't really
happen a lot and yeah uh now I'm also
thinking with your old job
in the Air Force where you're you know
you've got there's no room for any error
because you're dealing with nuclear
weapons that probably
that probably emphasized that type of
leadership more than because the other
thing about authoritarian mindset is
they don't do well in combat situations
oftentimes because they have a very
structured mind they have a very
predetermined way of thinking so they
get they get thrown something that they
didn't expect and they just fall apart
yeah you know the person that's great in
Garrison that's great at keeping
everyone great at doing inspections
graded keeping everyone in the proper
uniform they get into combat where all
of a sudden the enemy gets a vote and if
things happen they didn't expect and
people are getting shot and a lot of
times those people don't do well in
combat scenarios well there's something
about that this occurs to me right now
is that on consolation for that 10 month
nine month cruise I never heard of that
happening and you had two squadrons of
a7s two squadrons of f4s one Squadron of
a6s a Detachment of ra5cs and combat
Hilo Squadron Japan uh Squadron whatever
they were to I think there were two two
uh armored heavy duty helicopters and
and the guys who stood by the machine
gun I never heard of anything like that
anything like anybody anybody screwing
up or refusing or being unable to or
anything like that and they were using
real bullets and stuff there every night
yeah well it's an interesting thing too
about the Navy in general is that the
Navy in its nature
when you know from its from from the
past you know for you or my if you're a
commander in my fleet and I was going to
send you and your ship somewhere I
wasn't gonna be able to talk to you
again six separate Flags yeah and only
until you go over the run right and then
it was like up to you yeah and so we had
to we had to exercise a decentralized
command more than anybody else and that
really when you when you really pull the
thread on the SEAL Teams
that becomes very clear that that's one
of the reasons why the seal teams has a
reputation for being very adaptable and
figuring things out right because we
wouldn't get support all the time and we
had to you know it just being in the
Navy you you you had to figure things
out the other things that the other
thing is
in the Navy historically if you're on a
ship
you can't surrender yeah you you can't
surrender you you have to just fight
until your ship goes down there's no
quitting right because you'll die so you
end up with that attitude embedded as
well in the mindset
um but but the and I think you know
there's a lot of that with uh with
Pilots as well is hey look I'm gonna do
what makes sense for me in my aircraft
to make sure that I stay alive and you
have to make those decisions for
yourself and so it's on you well when I
was in Thailand
um to my shock
uh flying with facts Air Force facts I
never told them I was a previous Air
Force I I thought that's too
controversial I'm not going to get into
that I just let it go
and uh they see these guys Air Force
guys doing 30 degree Dives and I thought
that's crazy it has to be at least 45 at
least 60 and of course what I did was as
steep as you could get the hell with it
I'm not gonna get shot down here and so
forth but 30 degree Dives and I think
they all did that and they had the same
charts that Navy had
um so and the Air Force is known for
charts but maybe theirs were even better
that or more complete or larger than
what we had but you couldn't hit the
ground yeah I'm gonna dive in 60 degree
dive in the middle of the night are you
nuts you can't hit the ground what
happens if they got a tower up there
well he's still you're going to be a
thousand feet clear of that
so yeah but if you use a 6 000 foot
release and 550 degree dive at 550 not
dive in 500 not releasing the 60 or 80
degree dive you're not going to hit the
ground don't worry about it you won't do
it it can't you won't and what are you
pulling seven G's at the bottom that's
six and a half is what we usually did I
think
if you look down while you're doing it
the needle's just doing that just above
six so you you could you would look down
from time to time at that if you're
pulling out you don't know nothing else
to look at anyway yeah I think that's a
number you're saying as I as I listen to
you talk about it it is a little
surprising that you wouldn't do a
steeper dive especially in that in that
airplane because you're also more
accurate you know where your mom's gonna
go and to be quite honest like
six and a half G's is not that hard if
you get used to it and if it keeps you
right from from it becomes ordinary yeah
it's not that big of a deal any pilot
could get used to that I think the
biggest problem is people don't like
doing that stuff at night yeah and to me
is it's it's interesting that more
people didn't have the same logic that
you had which is steeper is better and I
just do the math I got a minute altitude
to recover from and if I pull back on
the stick I can survive six and fgs no
factor in right I'll pull out I'll be
fine yeah because the engineering
knowledge is right there on the paper
see it but
um dive seems I I didn't even know that
was even something that you were doing
and that's a shallow it's just a it's
especially in a place like that where
ground fire
not not the trip not the Sam's although
I know Sam's are always consideration
but but AAA like a 30 degree airplane's
a big giant airplane there's just a lot
of airplane to see at 30 degrees we're
at 60 degrees or 70 degrees there's a
very little amount of airplane to see
and I would think that's the math game
you would be playing as a smaller
platform I got one better than that I
was with this ov10 guy riding in the
back with the binoculars and these two
f4s showed up and they made about three
rungs from the same direction 30 degree
Dives one after the other that's crazy
are you nuts you always come in from
over there and one then that you made
one die from over there you over here
for your second we used to drop Pairs
and we have six 500 pound bombs and make
three runs with pairs but never from the
same direction never and when the lead
goes in over here trundle around the
circle and come in from the other side
because that means he's got to turn the
gun all the way around over there
because he was shooting at him the thing
is that's another thing about the first
guy in in the movies John Wayne is the
first guy in it's not a big deal they're
still getting the gun turned around and
he's off the target pipeline
Dash two dash three dash four and the
ones that take it out that's right so so
you feel like you're pretty good
prepared for that deployment you were
out bombing you were doing these steep
things getting ready to deploy I was
getting better at that uh and I didn't
get good at it until we were over there
and and uh and and
you know they they don't emphasize they
don't talk about the fact that there's a
lot of flack and you will see it going
by they don't tell you that because
maybe they're afraid of somebody said
not not for me I've got a bad cold and I
think I got a permanent cold and maybe I
do a lot better ah in Iceland and than
doing this
so I don't I don't know but uh
the other thing about
that being prepared was the the Advent I
said to David the the only my real claim
to fame here because I'm pretty ordinary
actually was the fact that I was there
when Sam Leeds walked around vf-121 and
said we're going to start this thing and
maybe you might want to be part of it
because we don't want to have any more
F4 shot down by making 17s not so much
21s but Nick 17s well what do they call
it was it called the advanced Gunnery
school do you know they called it Navy
advanced fighter weapons school okay
or it could I think initially they said
it might be called something like that
it was all very loose and I think they
had okay for somebody on the Admiral
staff in North Island but it was a very
uh loose and they said
if you volunteer
um you'll fly extra time and maybe you
don't want to do it because it's going
to be at six o'clock in the morning and
if you don't fly you have to be here at
six at four four Thirty in the morning
to man up and run the airplanes out make
sure everything on the airplane systems
engines and whatnot work and the radar
works because you're going to have a
experienced good guy in your back seat
just for this morning exercise so that
when we put two four airplanes out on
the parking ramp they all work and all
The Radars work so be ready for that you
will be here at 4 30 5 o'clock in the
morning and you won't fly
oh a lot of guys say forget that so did
you do it I did it yeah and uh
it was it was and you you will fly ACM
air combat maneuvering uh with
our instructors and so forth one of my
claims to fame is flying with Sam leads
in a in an A4 they had at that point
they had several generations of a4s and
they had two seat a4s and I think a
couple of single seats they had a much
bigger engine in them and they had for
the uh instrument rag at Miramar they
had coupled with the big engines in them
and that's when they flew at imitating
the mig-17 don't get close to the sky
he'll Eat You Alive which is true
and that's
Cunningham should have been shot down he
should have been shot down a couple of
times he's very lucky just lucky but at
any rate doing the wrong thing with Sam
Leeds isn't my bragging Point
um one of the few ones I he came in on
me trying to suck me into a what's
called a scissors it's two airplanes who
do this one trying to be slower than the
other guy and I rolled over the top on
him and went to burner and I was
standing there upside down above him in
burner
and he said I can still in my Minds I
see him looking up at me and saying he
said to me I can't believe you're doing
this which is the wrong thing to do
there would be a last last resort with a
mig-17 because if you screw it up he's
going to kill you
all Phantom and he was in an A4 yeah
but I was standing upside down on my
tail on in Max burner to do that and and
assembly maximum nice guy Dan Peterson
is a little bit removed a little bit
standoffish sort of guy not a bad guy or
anything like that but a little bit
stand up but Sam leads was a hilarious
sort of guy
at any rate he said he said to me I
can't believe you're doing that
Aviation and and the stick and Rudder
stuff
okay so now you're deploying to Vietnam
do you just load on the aircraft carrier
you're on the USS Constellation no you
go on a mini Cruise
um for uh Monday through Friday is what
it's supposed to be or was
um for a month for four weeks and uh uh
yeah well before you they let you near
the ship you have to
pure care qual that's all you do and we
went to the east coast to do that the
bunch I was with and uh
it was winter time
poopy suits back in those days rubber
immersion suits did you ever wear one
absolutely yeah good times what is this
in case you're ejecting into the water
the waters below a certain temperature
you die super fast so you got to wear
this immersion suit in case you eject
into the ocean so it's just a big rubber
suit that sucks I'm not going to
complain about in front of the seal but
it's not cool you know it's the water in
and air temperature less than a certain
number and they're not supposed to leak
but everybody that you know shoot
riggers and people like that and say
don't worry they all leak
and the other thing is getting into this
thing the the zipper goes from here to
down here somewhere so how do you get
your head through there basically
shoulders up get somebody to help you
and pull it up over your head and then
he lets go and it takes your ears off so
to speak and pulling down because it
makes a Tight Seal around your neck
and
above your neck I guess you have no
protection from the sea water either but
I don't know and then it around the
wrists or your hands are going to get
ice cold the the problem is you in that
maybe you know this
in cold water like that North Atlantic
and whatnot you stop breathing you can't
breathe you're fully conscious but your
whole diaphragm cools down and it won't
work for you so you're going to drown
because you now your swimming ability is
falling and the
um your diaphragm just will not make
get oxygen for you
some that you you're done but at any our
first my first traps in the F4 are in a
poopy suit
off Norfolk in March or February I can't
remember not that it matters and then uh
and then you then you board the carrier
and you guys
yeah once you get they give you well
they did I don't know how to do it now
but uh I think therefore they gave you
about four day traps one your initial in
my case I flew aboard if you fly board
you walk off but uh
your initial Day Trap and then next day
maybe two maybe one and so we're getting
you used to the whole idea and after you
have about four or five or six I can't
remember what it was then you can get
your first night which is throwing and
hit Nick Farr nixo where's Nick Farley
German uh what does it mean not so oh
okay
it was just being facetious anyway
um
I I got my first night I shot me off the
bow of America CV a66 and I thought holy
smoke is being shot into a cave and I
can't fly this crazy thing calm down Tom
all right you go up and around and get
on the downwind and don't look at the
ship they told you do not look over at
the ship it will give you a case of
vertigo or spatial disorientation do not
look at the ship like just look at your
instruments yeah and it was an overcast
night so a high overcast
I could see the ship in the corner of my
eye over here I'm driving on the
downwind
driving on it down I see it and took a
look
that's what they told you don't look at
the ship don't look at the ship I did I
can tell you well I don't understand why
why does it freak you out I have no idea
we told you Dave yeah like so it's just
a spatial thing you look at there's no
like what he's talking about there's no
Horizon you have no sense of where flat
or level or the sky and the water meet
so if you look over which we all do
because you'll find the downward if you
look to your left the ship is there you
cannot not look and
um and then the lights disorient you as
to when you see lights light should
either be above up or down so it creates
this orientation which you can recover
from by looking to instruments but the
don't look at the ship everybody's told
the same thing there's no line between
the Blackness that is the water the
Blackness that is behind the ship and
the Blackness that is over the ship the
ship is just sort of floating floating
into air space someone somehow or other
I'm getting dizzy just thinking about it
do you ever get used to landing on the
carrier well that's part of the second
part of this thing so I I got a board
and it went below and there's a
lieutenant commander nice guy from
Miramar who's there getting re-upped to
go to Sea and he's and I I went to the
ward room on Constellation the main Ward
room was the second deck so I went down
there I got my coffee and I got my donut
or whatever it was and he said pretty
dark out there and I said
I had no idea I thought I would know but
uh he said well you'll get used to it in
the daytime it gets to be fun in the
daytime which is true but nobody ever
likes it at night
which is true
Dave's confirmed 100
daytime could be fun night time not so
much that's right that's 100 True full
moon is pretty easy no it's worse
because you've got shadows and you'd
make a turn and the Moon is there and it
puts a light across your cockpit and
that it travels across and gives you a
mild case of special disorientation you
don't want that black is better and then
you just on those gauges and that's an
end of it until the guy says three
quarters of a mile call the ball
and assuming you're
on Center Line on on Clyde's Globe at
that point it's uh basically you just
got to wait it out but that's how I got
in trouble so which is in those notes
that you looking at mine different
different notes but it comes from the
same thing yeah what got you in trouble
I'm interested just lower your nose in
close come down one wire not good well
what's what happened well
you Bolter and what's that mean I'm
sorry no wire you don't get a wire and
the lights come on and they were off the
end to land
yes it can happen you can be innocent
and the wires are the wires are
staggered they're not the same space so
that if you have a hook skip
you can even hook skip two wires it has
happened and off the angle you go and uh
rats what'd you call it what's the verb
for it Boulder Boulder b-o-l-t-e that
means that you missed the wire yeah and
the lso he's very helpful you know what
he says
yeah thanks a lot
and so as soon as you as soon as you
miss you have to floor you have to well
yeah when you touch down you you go to
full power oh that's regardless okay
yeah basic engine uh and from time to
time on the f word anyway the engines
would be slightly misrigged and one of
them would go to Min burner and then the
ship would go ape and tell me oh no
you've got to do yelling at you come at
a burner and things like that didn't
mean anything so you have the Bolter
Boulder then what happens
um
yeah I guess the ship is on the same
their radar
facility the CCI is on the same
frequency and they hear the lso say both
Boulder and I'll say uh two and two uh
continue straight ahead to 500 feet turn
left heading bus and so which would be a
crosswind and then you do that
climate maintain 1200 feet or a thousand
feet or whatever it is and and turn left
to nothing so and then you're on
downwind and then they will you have
more planes coming in coming down from
the holding Chute if you will and
they'll squeeze you in in the middle
there
um so or that take you way down until
one guy is early and one guy's a little
you push over from those altitude had an
exact you're supposed to
to the second timing from the uh from
the stack and some guys are a little bit
early you guys are a little bit late
squeeze you in and they squeeze you in
uh in there and
then you get aboard the second time we
hope but at any rate uh why how do you
Boulder uh if you hook skip or you're
high and lay along so I get in trouble
because I boltered and uh just I'm not
going to do this two nights in a row
and it's almost unconscious lower nose
and close
what that's a move that you make to try
and make sure your plane comes down like
a safe
and they also call it taxi one wire
in that you land before or you're hooked
up well before the one wire new taxi
into the one wire so and I think Heavens
were aboard that's enough for this for
tonight and so forth so out of the next
say 10 nights I got well at the end
let's say I got six come down in close
so rule Gardner came to me and he said
Tom in the passageway too that's another
thing laid back in the passed away
tongue
I don't want you to fly tomorrow and uh
you're not on the schedule because I
don't like this
um and I normally Pamela Widow
oh we had been married about
14 months at that point so uh
he said I want you to think about it
this is not a punishment but I want you
to think about lower nose and close and
so if I fly that meatballed a touchdown
that was 100 of it
but that's the way he was leadership
again very laid back I don't want you to
fly rather than almost indicating if you
wanted to fly badly enough go to the
schedules office and tell them to put
yourself back on the schedule but uh no
you didn't do any of that just so you
Bolter boltered one time
no
like four out of six the week before and
that's why he did that God so once it
got in your head and it's almost
unconscious I think Dave can can vouch
to that you do it without really
thinking about it yeah you don't say I'm
gonna as soon as I get past the ramp I'm
going to lower the nose
it's a bad habit that you don't know why
you do it and and you do so after you
sit down for 24 hours and think
that is dangerous that is stupid and
you've seen
pictures Flight Deck pictures of Laura
nosing I'm not going to do that is it a
case of overcompensation Dave like
subconscious overcompensation that you
put you get over the ramp and you can
crank it down a little bit because you
want to be early because you don't want
to be long I think that feeling the the
first time you bolt her at night is a
really awful feeling because all you
want to do is land like you just you
would trade anything you have just to be
on that flight deck and so you do all
this work Tom was talking about the
timing down to the second there's a lot
of work to get you to three quarters of
a mile it's a lot of work from the stack
down to the end of the runway or into
the ship
and typically when you bolt or it's
because in the last probably three
seconds of a however long yeah or two
seconds you make one little error in the
last two seconds and it pushes you past
the wires by five feet yep and then
you're back in the air again and you you
don't want to be there and so when I
think in your mind you say when I get in
close the term is called in close to at
the ramp the last three or four seconds
of lying I am not going to add power
he mentioned something
earlier about something called the
burble which is a real thing and the
wind that goes over the flight deck
especially in a conventional carrier
that has to make its own win meaning it
has to run the engines to get speed you
have to have 30 knots of wind over the
flight deck that verbal the way the wind
goes over the flight deck and right at
the end of the runway it curves down
towards the water will literally pull
your airplane down just a couple of feet
but if you add the burble for three or
four feet it's going to pull you down
and that destroys part of your lip as
well absolutely and then that set that
psychological piece of I am not gonna go
high you know that six or seven foot
difference will put your point in the
back of the ship and and literally blow
it up that's the videos he's talking
about and I think the combination of
those two creates a really really
dangerous combination of the psychology
you talked about and the actual
aerodynamics of it and I would say just
a high majority if not almost all the
mishaps around the ship aren't really
because of mechanical engine problems is
because of that scenario and the lsos
probably went to the co and said hey you
got to talk to this guy because he's
gonna he's gonna kill himself and that's
when the skipper you know and I'm
obviously putting words in his mouth
based on common experience I didn't talk
about it specifically but it sounds like
I'm hitting close to the market yeah
yeah that's what happens it's all very
laid back too as a matter of fact the
lsos he earlier that night said to you
Tom this is a your third bolt of the
lower nose and close in a row this is
not good you gotta work on this and then
four hours later he came to me in the
passageway and said we're not going to
do this I'm going to change
Dave how often how many times did you
bolt or Bolter
I I probably so on my first cruise I had
no bolters on my second cruise I had one
boulder oh boy
in training
um when you're talking about CQ uh
Knight CQ I I bet I had at least one if
not two bolters at night what's night CQ
no I'm sorry Knight carrier
qualifications
before you deploy so the night CQ I've I
I had probably a a relatively small
handful once you're on you know like on
cruise and underway it's not it doesn't
happen all that often but
um the thing that's crazy is probably
some of the worst flying you'll ever do
is off the coast of California because
it's overcast at 800 feet all the time
even though it's beautiful Southern
California weather so it's pitch black
underneath that overcast even if there
is a full moon because there's a big
cloud layer there and uh the the Pacific
Ocean likes to move around the ship
moves around and it sucks it's awful
um so he flew a much harder plane to get
aboard the ship than I ever did so
you're talking about you might have had
four of these in your career and you had
four of them in that's five nights yeah
that's enough to freak someone out for
sure
I don't know yeah the F4 was an ancient
airplane in a manner of speaking in the
fa-18 is a different breed of cat
completely and I was told the F-18 is
actually fun airplane easy airplane to
fly and then yep and then you have to
work to get really good at it but that's
something else the F4 first time I flew
the F4 with my instructor in the back
cockpit we went back can you take off
and go out over the Pacific off Miramar
and
headed north and he said You Can level
off here at fifteen thousand or more or
less it didn't matter
and I tried to level off and I thought I
can't even fly this thing straight in
the level
but the F4 was designed to be an
unstable platform and then they put
three axial axis
stabilizing devices in there and the
early models had a single switch and
then they put three separate switches
for pitch rolling and yaw and a lot of
guys I at the end I would turn a roll
off most most guys did Total rule but at
any rate it was an unstable airplane so
if you touch the stick a little bit
it'll do that you touch the second it
turns off
the stabilizing system when you touch
the stick there are micro switches in
the base
of the physical hand grip and as soon as
you touch it a little bit it turns off
the roll stab you pull back just a
little bit turns off just a little bit
so actually before you
fly the airplane they'd want you to get
familiar with the cockpit and so forth
they say to you
realize that this system is there and if
it's quiet you can hear the micro
switches click and you can but you just
got to touch them and you click click
very faint but they're in there and
turns off they're all staff so here you
are your first time out with this thing
and you touch it a little bit and it
turns off the micro stab the the
stabilization in pitch and it does one
of these and because you go the other
way and it keeps it off and so forth and
then you push it a little bit this way
and it turns that off too and then you
go back and so forth there it only turns
it off for half a second or something
like that but if you hit it again
so forth and so forth and so forth yeah
so but the the fa-18 is a modern
airplane the F4 was just an airplane
that they Mr McDonald said I want a
monster and I wanted to do this that and
the other thing and and if you have a
problem with it won't do that add a
system to do that and they did and they
kept on doing that and that's what you
got you got a hell of an airplane but
my favorite quote about the F4 was a
marine and one of the one of the books I
as you might suspect I have airplane
books and whatnot and he said I flew the
F4 for three years and it never killed
me
[Music]
so you're uh so now you get to Vietnam
what's your mission what are you guys
doing Trail Ho Chi Minh trail Ho Chi
Minh trail Latin barcap
there was a Barnacles in the north and
the only things were going up there were
ra5cs to look at whatever changes they
made probably in the mostly in the
airfields and also looking for Sam sites
so you you being a first cruise guy you
were Not Gonna Fly that escort until you
did it
as I think that's a Navy tradition you
can't do it until you do it
so uh for the first three or four months
of that cruise I didn't fly any
Iraqi fighter escort up there and then
uh basically what happens is and
everybody I think is familiar with us
uh Fred's sick Tom can you do this yeah
I can do that so then you're at the
escort for the fighter for the ra5c and
then you're on the regular schedule for
that after that but that was the best
flying I ever did in my life that
keeping with him so what was that what
was one of those Mission profiles look
like
well
um launch and point towards North
Vietnam the coast and
they they were always looking around so
half the time they would see you on
radar and you you have receivers and
that are playing the F-18 probably has
better ones far better ones than we had
and you see him looking at you and it's
a as the sweep goes by and uh
depressurize the cockpit and uh
and give yourself a little spacing on
the ra5c and
he has promised that he will not go
closer than a thousand feet to the
undercast he will be above 4 000 feet of
the I'm sorry the overcast he won't be
won't get that close to the under cast
he will be
four or five thousand feet above the
under cast he won't go faster he won't
use burner and about four other things
and then when you get into it he does
everything that he says he wouldn't do
because he's in his pants too
because they're looking at you once
you're in there
they're looking at you with about three
different you can hear the different
tones different kinds of Radars so what
are they doing what's the ra 5c doing
taking pictures
he's a and you're just protecting it
right because the mig-21s shot down a
lot of ra5cs and what they would do is
they figured maybe they're going to do
it today and they put one or two mig-21s
at very high altitude that's above 35
000 because they get more speed out of
it
mig-21 would go 1.8 downhill easy
so they would wait until the ra5c turned
away from where their loiter is up here
and he's down at 2 000 feet taking
pictures and then come downhill behind
him so your job was to stay away from
him and always be looking back there
this side too because you never know but
always back here and so it would stay
away from him what people
in the
in the YouTubes and things like that
called thatch weave Mr Commander thatch
invented that in 1944 or something like
that and it's absolutely Air Force they
always write with each other and it's
just useless and a waste of fuel
we always stay one mile minimum mile and
a quarter is a little better so you can
come back and so forth so
watch out for mig-21 I wanted to be head
on with the mig-21 because with the F4
system well before that off the coast of
California
nobody ever told me you could do this
but I wondered against f8s I put the
pepper 35 mil pepper down the intake of
an f8 and guess what happened
them The Sidewinder growl which means it
sees Heat
looking just looking down the intake so
I want to do that with a mig-21
but I never got the chance
and I said to Jimmy I said when my best
friend
um
I said so that you can claim we got him
with a with a spiral we won't know which
because as soon as that Sidewinder
leaves I'm going to flip two because you
got the pepper on it I'm going to flip
to radar and pull the trigger a second
time so and I said when that big guy
sees maybe The Sidewinder won't guide
maybe it'll miss him by 30 feet and then
the kill radius is only 25 and stuff
like that but when he sees that spiral
coming at him that monster apparently
he's going to in his pants
so anyway uh how to get into this well I
was just asking what that mission
profile was yeah I saw it anyway you you
follow them around basically at high
speed and he always said he wasn't even
going to use burner and he had the same
engines that you have in the sj-79
would put out ordinarily put out a smoke
Trail we got a mod in the F4 late in the
cruise that would stop that and they're
in a fuel additive but and they had to
put piping in to do that but at any rate
you looked over at him and he's not
smoking that means he's in men burner to
get rid of the smoke as soon as you did
that the smoke went away
so and you look down and the max low
altitude speed on the F4 indicated
AirSpeed was I think like
740 and you you look at the indicated
AirSpeed and he's not in burner well
we're doing
790 indicated
relatively close to the ground and we're
smoking along here and then you come
back and they know what you've been
doing although it's combat situation
even not gonna have nobody ever
complains but I have a picture of an F4
coming aboard with and it's big dents in
all three tanks because you've been up
there
uh
if not at the Mark really close to it
the dynamic pressure dents the fronts of
the tanks and maybe they don't do that
anymore maybe put a some sort of a
reinforcement on the front end of the
tanks but those tanks were not
reinforcing the noses and they were all
dented from stuff doing stuff like that
from
this story is so cool for me because
that's that's like just classic nail
Aviation what I always loved about
flying with the Navy in the Marine Corps
was he's talking about that forward that
missile he was talking about in training
like the book says you can only shoot
the missile from the back of an airplane
that's the rule and that's how it works
and they tell you and the coolest thing
about flying with guys in the Navy
they're like I don't care what the book
says I'm gonna go try this let's see how
it works that's right this missile which
is on paper and designed to only shoot
the back of a jet because the engines in
the back that's all the heat is these
guys figured out I could shoot this
thing we've called four quarter in the
nose and the best part about that is we
launched this at a MIG I guarantee you
he would do exactly described because
nobody else would do that because the
book says you can't do it so I just like
I like listening to your stories of I
don't care what the book says I'm going
to try this and see if it works yeah
that if that big giant intake probably
replicated a mig-21's big nose with that
big giant engine right in the front of
the airplane that's pretty cool thinking
I like that and he had a 37 millimeter
gun too in both those airplanes and you
better not Shake It Fast Too Soon
because he's going to be firing that
thing on a head-on no matter which one
it is at you now you got a piece of
bulletproof glass in the front of you
and in the older airplane the F4U did uh
so it shouldn't hit you in the face I
guess but he's liable to ruin your radar
which could be a problem uh far If he if
he gets close to you with that head on
but as soon as you pull that trigger
he's gonna he never saw anything like
that in his life and he's been told that
the F4 has to get behind you so don't
worry about it and that's what I always
feel I know I said Jimmy you're going to
be able to we get that Mig with a with a
sparrow
because that's the uh the the rare
operators missile is a sparrow and so
what what was it that made those Recon
missions so fun for you just that you're
up there hauling ass around
um well this goes back to something I
put in that deal I heard chappy James
say it the first time and I think it's
common but don't get in the airplane
strap it on to you chappie James was
quite a guy and uh I talked to him once
once but and you know who he was no no
he was a black guy who was number two to
Robin owls in Thailand and Robin Knowles
got all the publicity and all this and
chubby James was the quiet guy who kept
his place and so forth and but they made
him a four-star general
uh he was
the night I talked to him he was a
speaker at a dinner and he had the place
in the palm of his hand and and then it
he figured he's probably winding up
about now and he said you've been such a
great audience I'm going to sing a song
for you and I thought oh the poor man
he's gonna ruin everything he had it
made here and now he's going to make a
fool of himself he sang Old Man River
like a Metropolitan Opera he was really
really something so and then he talked
with the troops after everything was
done you know he was right but then you
strap it on don't so that was
first time and I I felt that way truly
felt that way fly like the airplanes
attached to you and me
the other way around
because when he you want to stay a mile
or mile a quarter of beam what happens
if he turns into you well you go high
and you come up here this way and watch
him going around the bend and then you
can go to the app because you you're
coming down hill you're going to gain
energy so you can go to the outside if
you figure his next turn will be into
you again well then you can go up
without adding power because
as you go
no that that's wrong but if he turns
into you you can go higher would you fly
with the same guy all the time in the
back seat no the the the plane that you
were covering for no you didn't even
know his name no kidding yeah yeah and
they were all because they are they lost
a lot of young guys flying the ra 5c
early in its career they switched to
mostly
senior guys with a lot of hours and a
lot of traps they would lose them at the
ramp
um so they those guys were maybe they
were all Commanders
which is too old to be just an airplane
driver on a on a carrier but
because of the difficulty getting the
the monster and that monster aboard too
heavy their their launch weight was
little over 80
000 on on that thing and the standard
launch weight that has come to pass more
or less is around sixty thousand
so twenty thousand pounds heavier off
the off or getting the board
so
um they had senior guys uh doing that I
think there was one guy was a lieutenant
commander
but uh anyway flying with him
uh flying
I discovered I could fly like a bird
because he
um
at that point in your training or in
your experience level you get you start
to get that good at it and I thought
holy smoke I'm doing this this way even
though at that point I had a thousand
hours of Total flying maybe more than
that flying experience but uh it was
something of a revelation to be able to
fly
where you wanted to go and not be
limited by what the machine would do you
know
and especially with the F4 when you have
all that power and especially when
you're about halfway through your fuel
load you have a lot more power because
you
weight is is gone how long did the fuel
last how long did you have well the
Cyclone constellation and combat zone
was uh too uh
two two and a half
it was they called it a two-hour cycle
but you wound up playing two and a half
hours because they would launch
everybody and then they would recover
you so I think they launched it every
two hours I think that's how it worked
you know I never thought of it quite
this way but at any rate my traps on
combat zone were always about
2.6
did you guys get gas
only from time to time that's a long
time yeah and the F4 fuel gobbler and
you were always always slow sweating
fuel always sweating fuel
the cycle time they measure the cycle
time what he's talking about on an
aircraft carrier in the cycle time is
launched to launch so if it's two hours
that means a launch happens and two
hours later the launch happens what's
bad about that is if you're on a
two-hour cycle when you launch you'll be
the first one to go in your Phantom
and then two hours later the next launch
goes you have to wait for all those
airplanes to get launched before you
recover so that two hours is two hours
from takeoff to take off you have to
wait for everybody else on the next
launch to take off before you can land
so that two becomes two and a half and
30 minutes an extra 30 minutes is a lot
of time to manage your gas that's you
burn 100 pounds a minute yeah that's a
lot 100 pounds a minute yeah that's six
thousand pounds an hour yeah
um how about hitting the Ho Chi Minh
trail doing those bombing runs well you
always had a uh well what you do is no
your flight later I was always going one
your flight later would uh call
I think it was a piston engine Lockheed
Constellation that was out over the
water South
and he would ask you what you are and
what your ordinance was and you come
back and say your fact is going to be a
camera 2-2 and he is currently at this
and so of the lesson so tech and and he
will meet you at the thus and so and
thus and so of that attack in and which
would be somewhere in Northern Laos
and uh he he'll be there in 12 minutes
he's on route right now so you would go
there and uh
excuse me and you'd go there and we'll
wait a couple of minutes because if you
called him up early he'd say I'm I'm
going as fast as I can and and so forth
so anyway then he'd call you up and say
I'm in your area now here's what we're
going to do and he had uh what they they
called logs they were pieces of wood
that were four inches square and about
two feet long it had holes drilled
longitudinally in there and they had
Willie Pete inside and he had a way and
maybe they had a fuse or something I
don't remember that liked that and he
would fly over the spot where more or
less where he wanted you to go and he
would drop it out a trap door that he
had in the bottom of the airplane is
this true yeah and and then he would go
drop a second one and he said do you
have my my two markers and you'd say
yeah okay he said now they are Northeast
and southwest so um remember the
Northeast they're not North and South
they're Northeast and southwest and what
you want is on a triangle
pointed to the north
but to the Northeast and sort of and
there's a Crossroads there can you see
the crossroads and sometimes you could
on a moon at night he said okay now not
the crossword because but this is this
is really what you're doing yeah and you
say I drop another one but we don't want
to alert them because the trucks are all
parked right now but there's a Grove of
heavy trees can you see those no you can
I would always turn my lights out after
we get off the ship and and yet how
would you put it comfortable for a
couple of minutes I turn everything off
because I had a good or best Ro in the
back and uh and of course you can hear
this something's amiss in the airplane
what's that ticking what's that thumping
whatever the engines don't sound right
being near all that even with your
helmet on so I figured and warning light
panels for galore so if I could turn it
out
the human eye takes you probably know
this it takes about 30 minutes yeah half
an hour at the same length of time it
takes the sun to set so uh after half an
hour you can see everything on the
ground and the facts talking about that
grow of the trees yeah I can see what
you're talking about I can see where
that those roads are I only started
doing that after about two or three
months because initially you don't know
what you're doing but
turn the lights out and and turn the
parental lights all the way down use the
warning panels they they at any warning
lights low fuel or anything like that
that that's doesn't turn down as you
might figure so I figured and with a
good guy in the back
um he'll let me know so at any right and
then you're almost like almost daylight
when you
your eyes get truly acclimated and you
see everything on the grounds even if
there's just the least little no moon
but just Stars you can see stuff on the
ground saw it in there right that's
where you always running nighttime
missions 99 95 99 what would cause a
daytime mission
uh new on Yankee station the first day
maybe day two days in day days but then
after that all nights and you'd be on
Yankee station for
31 32 days well what's the Yankee
station Northern Gulf of Tonkin Northern
Gulf and initially they had a second
carrier they called Dixie station off of
South Vietnam but then they stopped that
and they would have two carriers in uh
up north excuse me on Yankee station
but anyway you turn lights out and you
could see everything at night and the
guy says can you see the dark the trees
and
Skipper wouldn't be able to see him
because he he's got older eyeballs than
me and he didn't turn his lights out or
turn them out completely that's what I
would do and uh he had good oral too and
he stole my good role when his Ro got
taken by the Admiral
um to be part of his staff then he took
my RO and then I had a teenager
didn't know what it was what he was
doing he was right out of the Naval
Academy but anyway
um so uh he'd give you those coordinates
and he said see that can you see the
trees that are is just south of where
that intersection is yeah anywhere in
those trees because it's full of trucks
uh there and uh and so forth sometimes
you'd get there and they would have
you'd see headlights but rarely rarely
and as soon as they really hear you they
run back to the truck and turn the
lights off or turn the engines off I
guess at any rate and then you'd you'd
do that but see that thing there that
you read early on that was that was you
know when Lyndon Johnson
had his bombing pause in North Vietnam
the North Vietnamese took all the guns
that used to be in North Vietnam to put
them over in Laos to guard the Ho Chi
Minh trail over there so
um
uh
and where was I the the uh the guns and
so forth and uh
uh well how often were you coming into
uh like you know you mentioned the the
anti-aircraft the Flack that you're
flying by yeah the surfaced air missiles
how how often did you run into that was
that every Mission every time
every time but they were cool about that
you see they you'd get there who was
cool about the Gunners on the ground the
enemy Gunners yeah in what way well
they'd know you were there because they
could hear you and um and uh in your
orbiting what I would do immediately as
soon as we get there I'd separate an
altitude I'd go a thousand higher on
whoever was usually a rural Gardener but
I'd go a thousand higher and I cut
across and turn and he every Naval
aviator is a left-hand turn expert they
all turn left in fact I one time I met a
guy in Philadelphia who had the same dog
as I did and I started talking with them
and and then I saw him second on the
third time he said what'd you do before
you did the ad business he said I was a
Naval aviator I said son of a gun so was
I how about that so at any rate I in my
office it was street level I had a old
IBM computer and I had the Microsoft
flight simulator early on a version of
that on that computer I said you come
inside and look at this thing I took it
off it made it take off and turned right
and he said what the hell kind of a
Naval aviator you
and it's it Sims
I can't remember anyway it doesn't
matter Sims nice guy nice guy but at any
rate I would turn I I would orbit to the
right
and I knew that he was going to roll in
from 1 8 I would roll in anywhere the
top of the of the quadrant uh of the of
the compass
Rose so what what made what the what the
Gunners do cool you said the Gunners
you make yourself present because you're
making all that noise right over here
over the crossroads and they know the
Gunners will know as the trucks are over
there and they know that and they know
that you know that because they can hear
the fact flying around too
so uh they would wait until you roll in
until you commit the problem is they had
to get a handle on you when you start
down because they also know I presume
that they knew because you're going to
pull a powered idle and your engines get
very quiet as soon as you do that
so they if they didn't have a bead on
you at that point I'm convinced too that
they used a simple auditory
way to track you I think my idea is that
if you took a bunch of paper towel tubes
and put tape around them and put a
microphone behind them and then you put
that on the Mount of a gun where your
gun that the barrel got overheated and
it warped so we got this
gun mount over here we don't use it put
that auditory
Search Finder thing uh on the gun
because then as soon as I turn it over
there and I can I got headphones on and
I can hear there he is oh I lost them no
I got them back again but the point here
is that the Azimuth and elevation on
that auditory device if you have a
simple system you can only five guys
having 57 millimeter or even 85
millimeter pieces around here they can
know they know where you are because
they can read what he is tracking you in
an auditory fashion so they wouldn't
open up sometimes
until you release pull and add power and
as soon as you did that
yeah that's you know going by from
the back
and
most of it right there because they had
time to know where you were and they
could hear you in orbit and now this guy
was over here and suddenly he got silent
that means he's in the dive so that
means he's going to be over here my
truck turned their guns around moreover
the guy with the auditory have a dozen
paper towel tubes
taped together he can hear you even if
you've got your engines at idle I think
that's my private Theory I don't know if
that's true or not but at any rate
that's when they would open up on you
and yes every night no question every
night anytime you were there they would
they would
Blast away in there and uh did you guys
lose any aircraft while you were on
deployment not my Squadron no ship lost
I don't know four or five maybe more a7s
no a6s
a a six guys I think were pretty cagey
A7 drivers they all tended to be
seemed to me younger guys in the ward
room sitting there where the guy said
man I had a hell of a time tonight I was
mixing it up with these guys they had a
57 millimeter and a cave on the side of
a hill I don't know how they got it up
there but I made I came back around and
gave him another load of 20 millimeter
really I said you know he's sitting at
that far across the wardroom table I
said you realize what what the aim point
is well it's the airplane I said no no
the aim point is right between your eyes
you're nuts put a 500 pound bomb into
that hole if you any good as a bomber
you can do that put a belt into into his
cave that's the end of that gun no it
was more fun I went around a third time
and I said you're crazy he's gonna shoot
you down you're gonna feel really stupid
you throw away your weapon is what you
do when you get shot down you'll have a
responsibility to
one in your book you talk about
things that are worth it and things are
not worth it and I I'll tell anybody
who's willing to live including an old
my old Skipper or somebody like that I
said I have favorite switch position
down by your left knee and the f4s and
all
it does all the bombs okay the missiles
the missiles stay but the bombs you have
singles pairs doubles cluster
all and and some and then all and flip
all this is bad here tonight I don't
want to be here I'll be back tomorrow
but for tonight
oh let's see if you can eat this load
there's only six of them for heaven six
what six five hundred Pounders yeah
that's that was our standard
bomb Alone six five hundred Pounders as
the deployment went on
and you're going out facing this every
night night after night is it every
night you flying every night yeah you
and when you were in the Gulf you flew
every night uh how's this wearing on you
mentally
ah not bad I think at that age you're in
your late 20 I was in my late 20s no not
a big deal except that
the air conditioning on some ships was
not very good and constellation was one
of them a flight Decker or the O3 level
to a Navy guy ran that air conditioning
pisses us off all the time well how
about if you just had good ventilation
you know they have 85 degree air outside
put 85 degree air in this room yeah it'd
be nice you know and my my
stateroom was uh you know three level is
the old old four levels to fly down so
there are places in the ship where the
where the air conditioning really did
work beautifully but we we had we got
visited by ABC or CBS News or something
like that and they were on Hancock which
was in the Gulf at the same time at that
time
and one of these guys said to me boy we
could see this ship on the horizon we
say this ship is nice a Hancock but next
week we're going down to get aboard the
big guy
air conditioning doesn't work here and
the food's not real good
run a Hancock in every way I said well
fortunes of War I guess yeah I had a guy
on the podcast named Dean ladder who's a
Marine in World War II and he went into
a bunch of different Islands but
he was talking he's going into Tarawa
and I'm like were you nervous going in
he said no it's the other guys that are
going to get wounded and killed that's
right he ended up getting gut shot in
tarawan was lucky a couple of his
Marines disobeyed the order just to keep
going and they grabbed him and threw him
back on the ship so I think that's the
common the common mental state of the
young man in combat that's right I
really feel sorry for the other guys
that are going to have trouble out here
and get wounded and killed my favorite
professor in College University of
Chicago PhD that's a big deal and econ
uh was a tail gunner in B17 so World War
II and I used to play chess with him and
I said to him what was it like he said
you always figured the other guy's gonna
get it that's the same thing yeah
that's a pretty impressive statement for
a tail Gunner B-17 of World War II he
was a teenager yeah yeah and he said
yeah he always fortunes of War you
figured the other guy's gonna or you can
always jump out you know yeah
that would be the worst of it that you
had to bail out any other highlights
from that deployment
well I I
think Skipper said to me um we want to
send somebody over to Thailand and since
you have Air Force experience would you
like to do it
oh yeah why not and this is to be a Ford
air control or something no just to
make some judgments and come back and
relate what how they do things over
there and how the facts work and stuff
like that so I said okay and so they
took me over in a Cod and we did not get
shot at broad daylight God went out in
the daylight and we didn't get shot at
the Crossing or anything out into ubon
is where I went where Robin owls was uh
when he made his
five kills and stuff like that and
initially hard to get to first base uh
there I said I got but it was like in
the movies they the card pulled out onto
the grass
and the crewman opened the back door and
they hopped out they had shut down the
starboard engine and
door slammed starboard engine started up
taxied away I was standing there with my
suitcase
on the grass
this is
Just Like A Goofy Movie from
France and World War II or something
anyway
so I I've got a guy a trooper walking
down the tarmac somewhere and I said
where's base operations
down the street but you don't want to go
there why because ah we're not allowed
to be here we're guests oh where do I go
uh building 386 it's on the second
street over and it has 386 on the
outside and I'm making this part up but
it's about an essence of it that's the
operations you want so I want to I
didn't have a place to sleep or anything
in my little suitcase someone went there
and it got a marine No Air Force Trooper
big guy
big guy with a sidearm at a little
lectern inside the door he said
basically he says who the hell are you
I'm in a Navy uniform and whatnot and he
said not without whatever he needed all
right so that night I went to the club
and I meet a guy an Air Force Major and
they said well we can take care of him
we'll get past that don't worry about it
and he took care of everything and stuff
like that but their Air Force operations
were officially just a guest and they
were just thrown officially the airport
was there the tarmac loaded with f4s and
C-130 so I got to fly with that guy uh
who flew the ov10 which is a heck of a
fun airplane to fly man oh man I swap
ends in a second with that thing I mean
this way and that sort of thing
tons of power two turbo prop engines and
designed for the Marines so I could put
one in a couple of guys in the back and
I opened a hatch in the back in the
Marines can parachute out into middle of
nowhere
stuff like that and
and a good panel in the barometer an
instrument approach with that guy and he
said that's really something off that
terrible panel back there I said yeah
well you make about 100 passes at the
ship and at night and it's not a big
deal anymore
now I flew with him uh maybe twice and I
flew with the C-130 gunship a C-130
Forward Air controller only at night for
him though because big Target I guess
um but we had flown off of that guy but
we didn't know what kind of airplane he
had
and uh let's see the ov10 and two times
with the C130 there's only there a week
um and uh
and then back out to the ship
um they
C-130 no
c47
had
about
eight or ten Marine Troopers who were
there on
r r at Ubuntu Thailand they had been
downtown and they all looked at
a big night last night
I don't know where they wound up going
but they dropped me off at Hawaii it was
right after the battle of the way that
destroyed everything in me and and right
next to the runway
Matt Runway and when we landed on that
mad Runway they're shooting at us
because it goes rattle rattle rattle and
I thought my dog or something but that
song was just a plank Runway
and then the Army was there and I
thought boy sandbags and logs and mud
and no I haven't had no part of the army
and anyway they sent a cod in there and
the Cod uh picked me up and took me out
to the ship so that's the end of that
but that was uh that was quite an
experience
um
those C-130 guys they had
cohomas
um they've sacked their parachutes back
over here and they have the pile back
there
really what do you do if you get hit
because in my mind you get hit you might
take the whole Wing off or the end of it
and it starts to Tumble and you're not
going to have time to put on a parachute
but they did I think they lost more
c-130s than they ever admitted to over
there
because well the one I was on a gunship
he's a three thousand feet and the 37
millimeter gets the 37 to 30 000 feet
and the burst went off in front of the
nose and I hit the deck behind the naval
flight deck on that airplane I was on
the floor and we as we flew through the
smoke
and they said
what was that I said For Heaven's Sake
it went off right yeah but it falls away
don't worry about it all right but we
threw through the smoke I saw the smoke
go over the windshield you know so and I
got the fly to C-130 a little bit just
steer it around you know not a big deal
but uh anyway that's what I did in
Thailand then I came back to ship and
the guy said what about this and what
about that and that's when I saw those
f4s
making multiple passes from the same
direction at 30 degrees at 30 degrees
dive and not just the same direction but
both airplanes from the same direction
so
maybe you're losing airplanes and I I
think I know why
no talking them out of it I think if you
are encouraged to think that 60 degree
Anglo dive is dangerous you'll believe
it
um
but it's not it's safer it's a better
way to go and when I saw that picture I
don't know if I said this now
there's a famous picture
taken during the Battle of Midway and
that guy is virtually 89 degrees uh all
above a Japanese carrier
so that's the way to do it I thought
besides he's got to get the barrel all
the way up there maybe he can't do that
so you get done with that deployment
um head back to the States now it's what
1970.
uh yeah and and you're coming back to
America now now you got the the protests
and all this stuff going on was that are
you seeing that are you aware of that
what's how's that impacted you very much
so and uh I think you just get used to
it uh the thing you wouldn't get used to
if you were a newly married guy and that
was me and a lot of other guys too uh
that they would call up your house and
say tell you that tell you your little
wife that you had been killed that night
oh this is Stateside uh before you went
to see
they're very evil that's that's evil
isn't it and then of course we had there
were a couple of bad actions there was a
Navy Cod I think an old one with a bunch
of guys on board that crashed on San
Clemente
um before we sailed and that was very
bad and made my wife very squirrely my
young wife first there's a funny thing
there's a funny one here I went to the
east coast uh and I flew out to the east
coast so then I have to ride back
so we're on a
DC4
C40 51 or God knows what a four engine
uh unpressurized Navy transport
and we get to Houston and the guy says
Ah we'll be here overnight because uh
the weed the I wasn't saw on the
third engine or something that's not
right and so be prepared we'll have it
it'll be ready by morning
so at any rate we were supposed to be
back at Miramar by 6 PM more or less I
sent her a caller or something from the
East Coast from Norfolk so she calls the
duty officer
the white hat sailor who's on duty too
he answers the phone and she says this
is Mrs Coppell he's my husband going to
be there tonight which is ETA and he
says oh no the airplane went down in
Houston
so now wait it gets better than that
she figured she was a widow what to do
about this
the next morning coming up the side of
the building or two guys with gold braid
on her sleeves
she said well
this is it steal myself
they're going to tell me what happened I
walk in the door
no anyway funny story and she still
likes to tell it to her friends from
time to time that's oh man
um so there is there's this 1970 you
come home there's obviously a lot of
division in America right
um and and what do you end up doing when
you get back
well the the
re-asked Tom if he wants to stay or go
and I said my father-in-law offered me a
job so I'm going to go and uh
too many dead Friends by that point too
and uh I said I I think I'll just get
out and they said well we want to send
you to be an ACM instructor at
Kingsville and I said I don't want to go
back to West to Texas I I don't like
that place he said well we could send
you to Meridian but it's only you know
basic instruction I said that's for me I
because a pal had told me that he got
plowed back at Meridian and his really
nice place nice people there and
everything so I said let me go to the
mirror and so they put me in Meridian
and I was an instructor there for my
last something like 14 months and I had
good students and mediocre instruct and
students and so forth and I wonder what
happened to the best of them I have
never been I've typed his name into
Google and
I had Marines bloody old Marines as one
guy who I was his instructor and then
his pal I flew with him a couple of
times they were Recon Marines which is
uh this Navy SEAL level stuff and I
foolishly said to one of them at one
point this is really foolish this is
naive
I said you got hiloed into Northern Laos
and uh you get dropped off in the jungle
and you know you're going to be there
for at least a week with plenty of
ammunition really what do you do
he said well we hunt for the North
Vietnamese there they train up there and
they're in the jungle and they're easy
to find because they smoke so much ganja
that you can smell them if they're
upwind from you oh really so what do you
do then
he said well you won't move around so
you are in fact downwind and then you
get close enough to them and you set up
and with your weapons and whatnot and um
you wait till dawn so they until they
start walking around
yeah then what do you do oh well we'll
kill them all
oh excuse me I was a little naive there
but these are the anyway
and the guy who was my student uh I
wonder what a nice guy both of them nice
guys
um
uh he would say to me Tom we're a first
name base even Marine captain at that
point Tom Tom how do you do how do you
do a barrel roll attack see that guy
over there make a barrel roll attack on
that guy
rich I'm not supposed to do that you
know that
come on
make a big rolling thing on on the
student flying students never look
around
he's flying over there hey a big mock
wow let me try it you go way over here
that's angry or the other thing with him
you're flying to buy a cockpit you you
haven't set all fighter planes or navy
trainers have rear view mirrors if you
need rear view mirrors in the fighter
plane
you're wasting your time you are long
gone
when I came back or let's say half from
halfway through the cruise you become a
nutcase in the cockpit at least I did I
want to know everything that's on the
horizon 360. that's the only way to
genuinely
be certain you're going to survive this
thing and and stuff like that so you
become a minor nut case looking around
and looking around and so forth into
which a young guy would say how the hell
you fly the airplane if you're spending
that much time well you do you get
skilled at it it's just time that you
get better and better at doing it
but I would have them turn their mirrors
so I could see their this much of their
face everything else is oxygen mask
helmet and oxygen mask but I want to see
this part there I want to see where
they're looking I don't want to see you
Mr Wilson looking at the panel I want
you looking outside Mr Wilson you're
down in the panel again I want your
outside to cockpit here well Mr Coppell
I have trouble flying level I said I'd
rather see you bumping around in a
little off altitude and then getting
shot down later because it's that
important and so forth so with Rich
Freeman I would like all of them so I'd
see him trying to Fly level and make Mr
rich I want you to make a 30 degree
angle turn and roll out of two seven
okay
doing a little bit of this and he starts
to get red in here it's a marine getting
angry and not good thing I said rich
don't get upset you remember I told you
you want to hold the stick with two
fingers and Trimble off the pressure
move it and then trim off the pressure
two fingers that's all you need I really
do it that way
okay we'll try it again I'll come back
three six okay it comes back and getting
redder
Rich dude you feel that in the airframe
yeah what is it I said that's me back
here pounding on the bowl he's got it in
the vice grip with White Knuckles and
his elbow in here trying to fly this
thing light Rich it doesn't work that
way but
anyway you got to relax I guess
I don't know I don't know I think when
you come back
and they're shooting at you and you get
bored at night in bad weather you're
soaking wet and you're tired so do you
burn more calories I think so there was
a study done
before the Vietnam War they did it with
a4s and I bet you
um David knows about this
they they asked these A4 guys to oh no
it was during at the beginning of the
Vietnam War that's how it would work
they put they had a recorder that
um put a pen mark on a on a disk of
paper
and then they wired these guys with
sweat and and lung
function and heart function and so forth
and they found out that what just what
they figured you go in and feet dry and
everything comes up and you get in the
Target area comes up even higher get off
the target area comes down a little bit
get feet wet comes way down
and it was way up here in the Target
area and then you talk to the ship
is up here
that much higher higher than the target
area right because in the at the ship
everything is right here whereas in the
Target area it's
fortunes of War
it's good tactics but to a certain
extent it's out of your hands
so you do your best but if you're going
to smack the ramp or do something bad
like that it's it's right there in your
hands and that was a4s
so yeah you you will burn more calories
in your
entire guy
and then you stand around the right room
and smoke cigarettes really
when did you quit smoking um right after
that I quit smoking
uh how was your transition into the
civilian life
difficult because you are
used to a guy who says that
he does that in civilian world's not
that way
a guy says can you loan me 50 bucks
until next Wednesday in the Navy he
comes looking for you and civilian world
you got to go looking for him
hey Eddie give me my 50 bucks oh I'll
give you half of it it's all I have I
say okay
so yeah he's a little bit Rocky and
I went in business for myself because my
wife thought that might be a good idea
for us and
the antique Persian rug business of all
things so I wound up making friends with
a lot of Persian guys most of them Jews
a couple of them I still know to this
day call them up saying how the heck are
you
couple of miles on guys all nice people
you had to be because you were sort of
all in that I like being in the Navy
here all in this mess together so you
I figured in that business I had it
because you have retail customers who
talk to you and say I've been looking
for a lesson so type do you know what
that is oh yes
I needed uh 18 feet but no longer than
19 and I need it thus and so wide and I
don't want anywhere but I want more of
this color and so
can you do that you get on as soon as I
leave you get on a phone call
Mohammed and you call Hakeem and you
call that guy and say I have what you
want and he will give it to you on your
signature
if your credit is good you know I
figured I called a guy one time and he
said I don't have it but I know who does
have it
he's an old Armenian guy and he's really
crotchety and he shouldn't be in
business anymore but he's got some nice
choice stuff this is in New York 28th
Street 31st Street
in that neighborhood Fifth Avenue and uh
I said I need this and that and this and
that and this and that yes yes
I I said my credit I said you don't know
me but I am I should call to us and so
and call him and you could call him and
I don't have to do that I said really
why I know who you are I could have it
on my signature so I drove away one time
with 80 000 in wholesale
value in the back of my truck and I
figured that was a mistake no signature
they know who I am sorry but nice people
a lot of a lot of nice people not like
what you read in the paper did you miss
the Navy oh yeah yeah
a lot of Pals and stuff like that but
you have to get away from that you can't
live in the past you know you gotta keep
going so
we had a lot of a lot of I keep saying
this but I had a lot of fun doing that
too so and my down to my wife
I bought a piece for several thousand
and
I came back like maybe two days later
and I said where's the uh that wasn't so
she said I sold it
she said I said I hope you got more than
fifty six hundred dollars for it
she said I got 75.
is that what one of those rugs cost how
much one of those rugs cost
it depends on what it is it depends on
its age it depends on its condition you
have to deal with somebody that you know
is utterly trustworthy because Henry
Kissinger got fleeced on a trip to
Tehran and he knew it after was all over
well what happened to him I don't know
exactly what the thing was but he
admitted to the fact that all he did was
take that load of stuff that I bought
and send it to a dealer somewhere to get
rid of it because it was junk and he
paid a bunch of money for it was very
embarrassing yeah and then you ended up
with a with in the bakery business right
bread making business is that where
you're at now yeah well this is this is
Jocko saying when you're in the middle
of the woods start walking and the guy
says which direction and Jocko says it
doesn't matter yes but I knew how to do
that so uh Pamela said why don't you
make some bread and
Pamela's brother is in believe it or not
in the Exotic mushroom business
and they have a outdoor Farmers Market
these are common in Pennsylvania on
Sunday afternoons and give them to draw
and see if he can sell them he sold them
all
doing it by hand
and solid same thing again next week and
so forth and he comes back and says Fred
says you ought to take a table here your
stuff is good enough I said holy smoke
but I can't only do so much by hand so I
had a guy that I did business rug
business with antique if you find
anything like that Tom call me I do and
so forth so I was coming I used I had to
buy all the time whatever you could so I
used to go to a lot of outdoor
country auctions more more of a country
than anything else and they had rugs
from the 30s
and a drive to Altoona as I did in this
case with with my truck Chevy van no
windows
and uh
I buy the rugs for fifteen hundred
dollars because there's certain human
psychology certain price levels in which
a retail customer knowing that
you could pay more but I won't do that
because I don't want surprises and stuff
like that so you know you're going to
get them for fifteen hundred dollars if
you drive off because you talk to the
auctioneer and he tells you more or less
what it is and he thinks he knows and
stuff like so you drive to Alton you
look at it and say yeah I can get 6 000
for this I won't pay more than have to
pay more than fifteen hundred dollars
and you do that so I came back from
Altoona that day to this guy's place and
he's in secondhand equipment business
secondhand commercial equipment ovens
and mixers and things like that they go
on forever
and he said Dave you won you bake bread
once in a while
and I just didn't I didn't buy anything
that day and I had money in my pocket
cash
in my pocket he sent uh he said I got a
couple of nice ovens over here I said
I'm not interested
to look at in their Diner size they're
not the full size you got to find
exactly the right guy you probably a
diner but he already has
shown to you for 900.
no I don't want them he said I can slide
them right onto your truck and he didn't
know I had money in my pocket either
well yeah he did
yeah maybe so he and finally I said okay
so then I had to install them myself on
a we live in an old Pennsylvania Dutch I
call him a
and Pennsylvania German soft brick
drafty and they have matching porches on
both sides and this porch was enclosed
so I put them on that porch and had a
heavy you know anyway I don't know a
thousand a piece I guess Jacks and
everything and blocks and getting it up
and sliding it over and installed both
of them but I didn't do very much until
my sister-in-law actually said you need
to put bread with Joe at the skip Act
Farmers Market on Sunday so but then
here one thing led to another led to
another
and then I went to this nice guy
Kimberton Whole Foods who's at the time
he had one store and he was on the floor
himself
and I said
do you think you can sell these he said
probably not because uh LA bus just
bailed out of here but you can put it on
their shelves if you want came back the
next day it was six of them so I said
can I put more of course so one thing
led to another he has about
maybe he has eight stores now and I'm in
five four so you're making bread every
day
I work no I work Tuesday uh Tuesday
Wednesday and Thursday and I deliver on
Wednesday what we I made on Tuesday
Tuesday night and sliced Wednesday
morning to deliver that then I work
Thursday
and deliver that on Friday and then I'm
off Saturday Sunday Monday
but I got another racket going what's
the other racket when I ran for Congress
I don't know if you know I did this I
did know that yeah it was in your notes
yeah
um
I was supposed to lose and it was in a
gentleman's agreement you want a guy who
can lose gracefully and they said that's
exactly right innocent okay but I
thought to myself this guy this
congressman
he drinks a lot and he may get hit by a
truck or have the classic too much
alcohol heart attack or something like
that this is the only chance I'll ever
get
so I I did I think I put it in there I
did run ten thousand doorbells I really
did it gets to be fun after a while you
meet new people and moreover they ask
you questions privately that you hadn't
quite thought through and after you
fumble around with that you say I won't
fumble around with that a second time
and turns out in the next two days later
a guy asks you the same question you're
ready for it
so uh after that and he spent 10 times
while I spent a U.S congressman I was
told will do anything to stay in office
anything
so at any rate he spent 10 times what I
had to spend as a 35 000 to spend he
spent 350.
but anyway
um and he wouldn't debate me either
um I finally went to this silly thing on
he was in DC because he couldn't quite
return which is baloney he
the county north of where we live but at
any rate
it wasn't going to say that we'll use it
had to do with your racket that you're
running your other racket
yeah well I was a I was a stock broker
at that point because of my when I had
my subdural hematoma they cut a hole in
your head and figure out of your hood
because I slipping phone about that but
I'd call it in there
you're John Glenn John Glenn fully
recovered and so have I but a lot of
people don't I think two it's a matter
of
wanting to and deciding to recover
because you with my case my right side
didn't I was on my left side and it's
true your left side didn't work right
and more work a little bit but not real
well and I couldn't walk right and stuff
like that and anyway uh so at any rate I
I had to get the the registrar I am I am
the Pennsylvania registrar for births
and deaths in Oley Township zero six
Township and for several surrounding
townships if you die you need a will and
to have a will you need an Executor who
just who distributes but you have to
prove have somebody prove this guy is
dead not just gone to South America and
so forth so you make certified copies of
his death certificate issued by
generally by the hospital or or the
coroner and that way your executor or
the man or woman's executive can
probate the will and so forth and all
that so at any rate
a year after well maybe 10 months after
I lost the election
I get to talk to a guy named Bob Asher
who was a little bit of a character and
well-known in Pennsylvania politics
because he took the Heat and went to
jail for something he didn't do but to
probably to protect a
Pennsylvania Senator or maybe one of the
governors I don't remember but he took
the Heat and everybody agrees that Bob
Denver did anything but he owns a candy
company called Asher candies it's
well-known chocolates and
Pennsylvania and there he was at this
affair so I went up to him and I said
Bob you owe me one he said get out of
here
you know I am poor I know around Who You
Are
said uh I rang ten thousand doorbells
yeah I heard about that
I said he had to spend 350
000.
to beat me
yeah
Bob we both know what that means he
would have spent 35 000 against the guy
in Fayette County he would have spent 58
000 with the guy in Pittsburgh he would
have spent
102 000 in the guy in the Harrisburg
race he spent it all to beat me
yeah so what Bob you owe me one
a week later
local guy that I've knew very well was a
whole
political office called me up and he
said how'd you like to be register of
will
what in the hell is that
so I said yeah that's right how much
does it pay well you won't make much you
can make 35 000 doing it you can but at
any rate they're trying to get rid of
the Pennsylvania register and now I'm
just sticking on because I figured I'd
break down to the last day
saw it anyway that's how that happened
so I was a stock broker and if you start
late in life to be a stockbroker you
don't have much of an account and and
stuff and I got to be a certain age and
I said to my wife this is this is not
cutting I got to do something else and
right after that my sister-in-law came
to me and she's a German National you
wouldn't know it she has zero accent she
said you sell bread that's good enough
sell in Germany you need to do this I'm
still doing it by hand and one thing led
to another there so that's what I do now
and it I'll tell you what keeps you in
shape you're not going to get fat doing
this unless you want to I suppose you
got to make sure you don't put too much
of your own product though that's true
just like the drug dealers no no no I
say to people people in stores that I
don't eat much bread I said it's not the
bread it's what you put on it the too
much mayonnaise or too much strawberry
jam is what you do with it not not the
the stuff well uh what's the name so
what's where can people get your bread
um you've got a shipment oh I got I know
what I'm not going to be going to the
grocery Market very often in
Pennsylvania but the only Baker the only
Baker o-l-e-y yeah that's an Indian name
for the valley in which we live the
Indian God for it was olinca and that
got shortened by the by the locals at
that time way back Benjamin Franklin did
not like to come up to that County he
said there were too damn many Germans up
there I don't like to go up there he was
a good horseman in his the middle age we
all see Ben Franklin as a big fat old
guy oh yeah that old man but he was an
expert expert uh Horseman and people did
not like to travel with him well I read
an account of him going to York PA which
is west of Harrisburg they didn't like
that with him because he would take off
over land to basically explore the
landscape and whatnot and they're all
afraid he was going to either fall off
or get killed by locals of the Indians
so they thought then we're going to have
to go look for him and find him and the
the some of the folks out there don't
like us very much and so forth so people
did not like to go traveling with him
but he was an expert in an Overland a
Horseman
but we will see him as the the fat old
guy yeah that's the that's the image he
got stuck with at some point right I
know you uh you know you wrap up your
your bio that you sent to Dave and it
says 2022 still having fun heck yeah so
that's pretty awesome I don't know did
we miss anything
get us up to date
there's one thing I thought about on
going by now it now it Escapes Me
same marriage married to the same woman
this is during the political campaign
they would ask you are still married to
the same woman
since uh
h27 wow so I got married a little bit
late and it was your daughter that
brought you here yeah and then linked us
up I think she linked us up on social
media yeah there was a elder daughter
Genevieve and uh she wanted to come with
me but she is in a job that she doesn't
like and she's intensely searching so
the other daughter said I'll take him
out and she had not actually said she
said if you go I'll buy it my own ticket
okay
so I then I said to you I will not
travel alone I will travel with my wife
oh okay
so then Pamela said I don't want to go
we have a ancient puppy dog here and
she's going to die so we ought a
euthanizer I can't do that
that's the pragmatic solution apparently
so younger daughter said I'll go with
him so she is here today in San Diego an
elder daughter is uh angry but I said
Jenny
um what you're doing is more important
and uh
she's working it she got into the
medical world as most specifically into
transplants and she said if choco says
anything to you ask him if he is a uh
organ donor and of course and he should
be everybody should I am yeah so I'll
tell her that but at any rate she's
going to know apparently everyone's
going to know that I said but the thing
about Jenny the thing that people want
is something you can do that most people
can't you can keep six balls in the air
at the same time so to speak that's why
these guys in the transplant business
love you so much because they could say
oh I don't know about that ask Jenny and
the answer or this computer thing is
screwed up and it and it's off the thing
and it won't work
call Jenny she can do that and she does
so the younger daughter they have the
machine her husband have their own
business so it's easily done for them
although they're very serious and they
do well
so that's the whole thing there
was something else
Dave what do you got oh man I got a lot
boom I know we're we're Connor I've been
taking a lot of notes
um
I just
I'm remarketing how many similarities
they are and I just started writing
things down I was stationed at Meridian
I was stationed at Kingsville
I was in lso I have about 40 traps in
the Connie early in my career how about
that yeah I uh I did the spin rides in
the t2 and I knew her spin instructor I
know that well it's fun it's a great I
said they were one of those things I
said it's great carnival ride so many
times what about doing I used to say
that
the student didn't know who I was I'll
I'll be doing your spin hop today
you're terrified
well no Mr Coppell but I thought that I
said wait a minute wait a minute how
many guys have you been punched out on
spin hops
oh I don't know no one
it's a carnival ride and so forth uh and
Fred didn't want to I hadn't met kids me
though I don't like to do that I'll do
them I'll do them for it so I would do a
lot of the spin off somewhere in there's
a carnival ride
not much instruction goes on that day
except for the rote all right Mr Smith
we established the direction of rotation
and we will positively neutralize the
controls and then apply full opposite
Rudder and when the rotation stops we
will uh
put stick full forward and so forth yeah
that's all you do and then okay fine
we've got that now we're going to climb
back up here you have to do it again
yeah I'm going to do it again too
oh I remember it well some of the best
rides ever yeah
um
my time with the Air Force and then you
kind of conclude with a couple of things
that just couldn't help make the
connection to living on the O3 level in
the state room underneath the catapults
and then God forbid I am on a podcast
where I don't have to say something nice
about Navy Seals but you work for a frog
man and got to see what what what what
real good leadership but you know what
he don't spoke about leadership just a
second he was not well thought of mostly
by the younger guys who are Ross and the
flight squatter and I was in and he
never does anything and well he talkins
and they would say not nice things about
them I don't think any of the front seat
guys said that what a surprise but but
the the backseat guys they're all young
and the
lieutenant Junior grids all of them
solid and most of them retired as
commanders I don't know what the heck
they got him to do to say in this in the
Navy that long but at any rate they
didn't like him because they couldn't
understand what he was doing I think the
front seat guys all really understood
what was going on there well I think
there's a real strong connection between
pilots and seals I got to learn that
firsthand working with Jocko but yeah he
did it at a time you did it at a time
where he
you didn't have the machines that we had
I mean you flew an airplane that I
guarantee you was infinitely harder than
it was for me yeah but it occurred to me
that the the Legacy that I got to live
under the 35 years of History was
written about people like you and when I
got them when I got in the Navy in the
Marine Corps
how we flew Fighters and the way we
taught people to fly Fighters was
already embedded and that all started
with your generation so but you know
that's what I was thinking about in that
Dan Patterson and and the book that
wasn't called Top Gun until maybe I
don't know three four five years later
somebody said top but the F4 didn't have
a gun and I don't and and all your
newspaper guys they'll say well I had to
have a gun and I finally did the f4e and
had a gun in it finally no the missile
was a better weapon every time every
time he had to be within three thousand
feet to do anything with a 20 millimeter
gun I shot the gun at Kingsville we all
did
bad at it too I don't know
they put your colored paint on your uh
and and then they examine the banner
there are no Greens on here what
happened to you Tom and
embarrassing you know I'm an older guy
I'm supposed to have holes in there but
at any rate uh
I don't I utterly disagree with that
business about if any sort of a fighter
plane you have to have a gun ball Lonely
Now early on sparrows didn't work
because the white hat Sailors would drop
them and
chalk them up into the bottom of the
airplane and they they didn't test them
to see make sure this is working and
things like that and then the aviators
didn't turn the panel on and to see if
the missiles they called it tuning that
the missiles would tune and things like
that and then if one didn't tune you
flip past that to go to the number two
and so forth and fire that one forget
about the first one but then you could
do one more thing that came out during
Top Gun that nobody during advanced
fighter weapons move if you went to bore
sight tell the guy in back cockpit go to
bore site the antenna goes where the the
pepper is through the 35 mil gun side is
looking they're both looking at the same
place and that's what I was going to do
with the 21. go borsak pull the trigger
and and
get a spiral which is a moss or mezzled
why five weighs 500 pounds the sparrow
the ones we had anyway the e-models
weighed 500 pounds but anyway
um it wasn't called fire weapon school
back then oh yeah so the fun the thing
you read in Dan Patterson's book who
remains a nice guy
but I would say this to him in a clear
way most the airplanes shot down in
World War One
in World War II in Korean war in the
Vietnam War
never saw the guy that shot them down
they never saw the missile that shot
them down I know I knew guys who came
out feet wet
out of North Vietnam
and saw the missile go by the B model
missiles the missile the Russians had
they stole it from us and shipped it
through Berlin on Commercial Freight
and it didn't guide that well at least
the Russian version of it didn't it had
a big Seeker head on it and and it
didn't narrow its sight but I talked
with guys who said I I saw the missile
go by and I had no idea
yeah
holy smoke most guys who got shot down
and I heard this early in the cruise not
until I was um out there and
get fully realized that they use real
bullets here and stuff most 95 percent
of the airplanes that got shot down get
shot down and they never saw the the
whatever did it to them they never saw
it one time we were in laws somewhere it
doesn't matter where
waiting for the fact and he's at 14
November 15. he's in a port orbit and
I'm in a starboard a little bit and
we're just waiting quietly
and here comes
nf4 you can tell because it has at the
wing roots and the Leading Edge of two
flashing white lights
that's an F4 and he comes flying by and
he gets about where we are that's where
there are guns on the ground because
that's where there are trucks park and
that's where the fact is going to meet
us and those Gunners can hear us up
overhead But Here Comes this guy over
the horizon
an F4
at this guy with probably 57 at least
maybe 85 millimeter
still got his lights on bright and Flash
and he disappeared over the horizon
Brighton Flash
did you go get close to him I'm not that
close because they were shooting at him
but I want close enough I could see that
is an Air Force F4 it's not some some
Navy guy who's lost or something it's
Air Force
F4 and he never knew it
oblivious to everything with his lights
on bright and Flash it's a true story so
my point here is that Top Gun is or what
they call now talk about it's very
interesting if you go one-on-one you
both start from here you turn hit and
start with a head-on pass and so forth
one guy is better than the other and he
gets behind the other but that's not
what happens what happens is the guy
that you were picking your nose for some
reason or other and the mig-21 showed up
or a mig-26 or God knows what it is and
he shot you down from three miles of
stern
because you were picking your nose you
got to be a wild man in that cockpit if
you don't want to get shot down you got
to know what everything is going on 360
Degrees all the time so you turn into a
crazy man and you fly with a new Ro he
said you're really nuts yeah I'm still
here too
that's all I doubt man so at any rate I
beg your pardon I interrupted not at all
right that's probably a great place to
wrap it up right there all right now
that's a great attitude to have
um thank you so much for coming out here
it was fun
thanks for sharing your experiences
Lessons Learned
um and of course
most important thank you for your
service oh baloney so thank you for your
service in the Air Force and and your
service in the Navy uh and most of all
thank you for your service to our great
nation amen thank you sir
and with that Tom copel has left the
building
uh pretty awesome to hear from a dude
that
as you were telling me and uh before we
hit record Dave
in the middle of the Vietnam War just
volunteers to go and fly you know F4
Phantoms
that's the pipeline too
so pretty amazing to hear these guys I
thought it was actually pretty
interesting about the nuclear war stuff
too
yeah you know like what what are you
thinking what you you know like I was in
the SEAL Teams and I was like hey we
might do a mission in the 90s like hey
we might do a mission Michael
you know kill a terrorist this dude's
like hey we might go and end Humanity
yeah you know that's a I remember when I
first started flying airplanes what you
really want to do is you actually want
to you want to do something you want to
drop a bomb you want to get in a fight
you that's what you want to do
and there's a double edge to that
because you know like well
I mean we don't want to go to war it's
not a good thing but if you do you like
you want to get the call the only thing
you're ever going to do when you're you
know strategic area of command with
nuclear weapons and a B-52 you get that
call like
that's a different psychology about what
your job is you know and I could see
someone like him getting pretty restless
doing strip alert all day knowing it's
kind of unlikely and even if it did work
out like what are you actually doing
there that's that's not a scenario you
want to be in no matter what so yeah
crazy
um but anyways thanks for listening if
you want to support the podcast you want
to support yourself
get yourself some Jocko fuel
jocofuel.com you can get these these
drinks we're drinking right here
get yourself some afterburner orange
the tasty flavor
um Mulk
going ham on the milk we got we got
ready to drink milk now
people are kind of going crazy with that
stuff I'll tell you what's what what's
what I find
ah look just like every other freaking
American the convenience of just
cracking one of those open and drinking
it look how much effort is it for me to
get out my get out my milk get out my
shaker put my milk in there shake it you
know that has to take me at least
three minutes
or I got that little ready to drink
hitter just ready to you know take some
the other thing I find about it is
you can just you can it's so effortless
that you can just open one up like I
have I have a part of my fridge where I
have one of each kind of opened where
I'll just go like take a sip take maybe
two or three sips you know just during
the day just a fly by
um
so there you go
Mulk all the joint stuff you know what
you know what it is um you can get it
dockerfuel.com you can get it the Wawa
get the drinks at Wawa get a vitamin
shop
um go get some support origin USA
I saw cam Hanes today posted cam is
teaching Tulsi gabbard how to shoot a
bow and they're wearing origin hunt man
how legit is that pretty awesome so
check out originusa.com we're making
stuff in America jeans
Jiu-Jitsu geese boots
t-shirts rash guards all 100 made in
America
so get some of that
we got a store
Echo called Jocko store it's Jocko
store.com get t-shirts what are you
wearing oh that's a legit one so Dave
right now if you're not on YouTube
Dave's wearing The Sea Wolves t-shirts
1966 to 1972. the only Aviation unit
ever commissioned and decommissioned in
a combat zone
we've had some Sea Wolves on the podcast
there's a t-shirt to represent the Sea
Wolves uh you can get that at
jockostore.com
um we also got rash guards and hats and
beanies and all that kind of stuff we've
got the shirt Locker
sherlocker is
it's a little opportunity for
us to express kinda
let's say some deep layers to the
podcast and it's a subscription thing
gives shirt a month and they're cool
we got this podcast subscribed to a
Jocko Underground
we're doing the underground podcast
which is also a platform that we have
that we control because if you're not in
control of a platform you should be
nervous
that they could kick you off that
platform so I was nervous about that now
look I'm not trying to get kicked off I
don't think I'm gonna get kicked off
we're not getting crazy over here
but there's certain things I've said
that have been
uh demonetized
so who knows when they're going to say
yeah you can't say that anymore so we
have our own platform Jacko
underground.com check that out YouTube
channel
Jocko
podcast is the YouTube channel origin
USA also has a YouTube channel we've got
psychological warfare we got Flipside
canvas Dakota Meyer got a bunch of books
only cry for the living by Holly McKay
final spin the audiobook of final spin
Dave and I did like a q a from final
spin at the uh so after the book you can
do the Q a you can listen to that q a
it's pretty cool
the background of where it came from
I can tell you where it's going that
thing's making moves I'll leave it at
that for now because it's hard to get
these things done but anyways written a
bunch of books
Warrior Kid books
just I have a gym Victory MMA and
fitness and just about every day a
parent will come up to me and say
thank you for those books that got my
kid to focus in school got my kid here
to start training Jitsu got my kid to
stop eating junk
so check out those books for your kids
way of the warrior Kid series
Mikey and the dragons hackworth about
face extreme ownership dichotomy of
leadership all these books you know I've
written them get them if you want them
Ashley on front what's actually on front
Dave Burke Echelon front is our
leadership consultancy where we
you me Leif and the whole team get to
actually in person live talk about every
single leadership principle you've been
talking about on this podcast and in the
book we get to do it with companies and
people all the time it's
it's awesome and what about the academy
oh the academy
the extreme ownership Academy it turns
out that meeting people live and in
person isn't always the most convenient
way to do it and bringing people off the
line and bringing people into a
conference room or a classroom every
single day is not a great way to train
we want to keep people working but the
academy takes basically everything we
teach puts it online so you can get to
it whenever and however you want to and
it's an awesome additional resource
it's basically be able to hit that
leadership gym every day whenever it's
convenient for you so we got the academy
yeah just like Jiu Jitsu there's moves
you got to learn there's moves you've
got to learn about leadership and just
like you just you can't just look at a
move and hear it one time and be like
okay I'll throw this Uma Plata on
somebody now this is not going to work
you gotta you gotta fully understand it
you gotta see it from different angles
you got to try it yourself and that's
what the that's what the academy is
Extreme ownership.com if you want to get
in on that and if you want to help
service members active and retired you
want to help their families
you want to help gold star families
uh check out Mark Lee's mom mom Elise
you got a charity organization does
incredible stuff
does incredible stuff takes service
members this is one of the one of the
things that she does she takes service
members who have significant health
issues and she gets them treatment it's
a multi-faceted treatment one of the big
treatments is hyperbaric chamber so
you're going in right in the io2 she
sets this up for like 30 or 45 days all
expenses paid so and we've seen the
results of this is just outstanding so
if you want to donate or you want to
support that go to America's Mighty
Warriors dot org and also don't forget
about Micah Fink who's taken vets up
into the wilderness
to heal
through adversity
which is pretty awesome Heroes and
horses dot org
and if you want to follow us on Twitter
on Graham on the Facebook Dave is at
David R Burke I'm at Jocko willink watch
out for the algorithm
uh thanks once again to Tom kopel
for making the trip out for sharing
those experiences and lessons learned
from your life
pretty neat to hear this stuff first
person
thanks for your service
thanks for coming out and thanks to all
our military personnel with a special
recognition today
to those of you that help us own the
skies the pilots The Navigators the air
Crews the maintenance and mechanics on
the ground and the thousands of support
people
that make our domination
of the air possible
thank you for what you all do
and thanks as well to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service all First
Responders thanks for what you do here
on the home front to keep us safe
and I want to close this out with uh
another quote a quote from Captain David
mccampbell United States Navy
34 air victories in World War II the
most of any U.S Navy pilot ever
and he said this
quote aggressiveness was a fundamental
to success in air-to-air combat and if
you ever caught a fighter pilot in a
defensive mood you had him licked before
you started shooting
end quote
so there you go
that just doesn't apply to air-to-air
combat it applies to everything that's
how you win
so get out there
be aggressive
make things happen and of course
keep getting after it and until next
time this is Dave and Jocko out